It's been four years since I first learned about the disappearance of Neyam May, an 18-year-old who went missing from the small New South Wales town of Batlow back in 2002. I don't know if it's because Neyam and I finished high school in the same year or we shared a similar taste in music, but I felt instinctively drawn to her story. As I learned more about Neyam's story, the revelations that unfolded left me in shock. The result is Missing Neyem, the latest 12-part series from Casefile Presents. Researched and hosted by me, the series features exclusive interviews with key players who help us dive into the details of Neyem's case as we go back to Batlo to try and make sense of
距离我第一次听说内亚姆·梅（Neyam May）失踪的消息已经过去四年了，她是一名18岁的女孩，2002年在新南威尔士州的小镇巴特洛（Batlow）失踪。我不知道是因为我和内亚姆是同一年高中毕业，还是我们有着相似的音乐品味，但我本能地被她的故事所吸引。随着我对内亚姆故事的深入了解，随之而来的真相让我感到震惊。其结果就是《寻找内亚姆》（Missing Neyem），这是Casefile Presents推出的最新12集系列节目。该系列由我负责研究和主持，通过对关键人物的独家采访，帮助我们深入了解内亚姆案件的细节，同时我们回到巴特洛，试图理清
what really happened. The entire 12-part series is available now. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. In the winter of 1996, Stacey Gaylord stood by the water's edge at the Sydney Olympic Park Aquatic Centre. As a member of the Balmain Women's Water Polo team, it was a familiar scene for Stacey as she and her teammates milled around the poolside in their's Water Polo team, it was a familiar scene for Stacey as she and her teammates
到底发生了什么。整个12集系列节目现已全部上线。请收听今天节目的结尾，那里有预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。1996年冬天，斯泰西·盖洛德（Stacey Gaylord）站在悉尼奥林匹克公园水上中心的水边。作为巴尔曼女子水球队的一员，这对斯泰西来说是一个熟悉的场景，她和队友们穿着泳衣和泳帽在池边徘徊，
milled around the poolside in their swimsuits and bathing caps, waiting for their training session to begin. When it came time to enter the water, Stacey glanced over and noticed that her friend and teammate, 21-year-old Kelly Lane, was sitting on the edge of the pool with a towel wrapped tightly under her arms. She held it there until the very last moment before dropping it to one side and discreetly slipping into the water. Stacey found this unusual. Kelly was an accomplished athlete who'd been competing in water sports all her life. She was no stranger to wearing her swimsuit in public and until relatively recently, she typically walked around confidently in her bathers before diving straight into the pool. Stacey had also noticed that Kelly had taken to wearing tracksuits over her swimsuit, no matter the weather.
在池边徘徊，等待训练开始。当轮到下水时，斯泰西瞥了一眼，注意到她的朋友兼队友，21岁的凯莉·莱恩（Kelly Lane），正坐在泳池边，双臂紧紧夹着一条毛巾。她一直紧紧抓着毛巾，直到最后一刻才将其扔到一边，悄悄滑入水中。斯泰西觉得这很不寻常。凯莉是一位出色的运动员，一生都在参加水上运动。她对在公共场合穿泳衣并不陌生，直到最近，她通常都会自信地穿着泳衣走来走去，然后直接跳进泳池。斯泰西还注意到，无论天气如何，凯莉都开始在泳衣外面穿上运动服。
Stacey had her suspicions as to why. She put her goggles on and ducked under the water to catch a glimpse of Kelly's body. It was just as she suspected. Kelly Lane was pregnant. This was significant for several reasons. For starters, the two were close friends, and Kelly had never once mentioned that she was expecting a baby. Secondly, water polo is a physically demanding contact sport in which injuries are commonplace, not the type of activity one would expect to see a heavily pregnant woman participating in. Stacey knew Kelly's long-term boyfriend, rugby player Duncan Gillies, and she assumed the couple had decided to keep the pregnancy quiet. Respecting their privacy, she said nothing to Kelly about it. Stacey didn't see Kelly play another game after that.
斯泰西对原因有所怀疑。她戴上护目镜，潜入水下，想看一眼凯莉的身体。正如她所料，凯莉·莱恩怀孕了。这在几个方面都很重要。首先，两人是好朋友，而凯莉从未提过她怀孕的事。其次，水球是一项体力要求很高的对抗性运动，受伤是常有的事，这并不是人们期望看到孕妇参加的活动。斯泰西认识凯莉的长期男友、橄榄球运动员邓肯·吉利斯（Duncan Gillies），她以为这对情侣决定对怀孕保密。出于对他们隐私的尊重，她没有对凯莉提起这件事。此后，斯泰西再也没有见过凯莉参加比赛。
A few weeks later, she noticed Kelly was no longer pregnant. It occurred to her that Kelly must have given birth, but she didn't stop to think about what had happened to the baby. Just short of three years later, on Wednesday June 2 1999, Ankle Care Adoption Services social worker Virginia Fung arrived at Ryde Hospital in northern Sydney. A young patient had called the agency the previous day with a somewhat unusual case. She had just given birth and wanted to place her baby for adoption. Virginia was a little taken aback. It was incredibly rare for a new mother to make such a request. The adoption process typically began much earlier in the pregnancy,
几周后，她注意到凯莉不再怀孕了。她想到凯莉一定已经生了孩子，但她并没有停下来去想那个孩子发生了什么。不到三年后，1999年6月2日星期三，Ankle Care收养服务机构的社会工作者弗吉尼亚·冯（Virginia Fung）抵达了悉尼北部的莱德医院（Ryde Hospital）。一位年轻的病人前一天致电该机构，提出了一个有些不同寻常的案例。她刚刚生下孩子，想把孩子送去收养。弗吉尼亚感到有些吃惊。新妈妈提出这样的要求极其罕见。收养程序通常在怀孕早期就开始了，
with appropriate arrangements already in place by the time the baby was born. with appropriate arrangements already in place by the time the baby was born. Virginia was introduced to the patient, 24-year-old Kelly Lane, and her two-day-old son, Jacob, not his real name. Kelly explained that she'd been living in London for the past year with her boyfriend Duncan Gillies, a professional rugby player who was still in the UK. boyfriend Duncan Gillies, a professional rugby player who was still in the UK. The couple had recently broken up and she didn't feel able to care for a child. Not only was she due back in London for work in a few weeks' time, her parents weren't happy about the pregnancy and couldn't offer any help. Duncan wasn't prepared to be a parent either, so they'd agreed their best option was to have the baby adopted.
并在孩子出生时就已经做好了相应的安排。弗吉尼亚被介绍给了这位病人，24岁的凯莉·莱恩，以及她出生两天的儿子雅各布（Jacob，化名）。凯莉解释说，过去一年她一直和男友邓肯·吉利斯住在伦敦，邓肯是一名职业橄榄球运动员，目前仍留在英国。这对情侣最近分手了，她觉得无法照顾孩子。她不仅几周后就要回伦敦工作，而且她的父母对她怀孕并不高兴，也无法提供任何帮助。邓肯也没有准备好当父亲，所以他们商定最好的选择是让孩子被收养。
Virginia was a little concerned. Kelly appeared to be a doting mother to Jacob. Virginia worried she'd made a rash decision and might change her mind in a few days' time. She began making arrangements to place Jacob into short-term foster care while Kelly was discharged from hospital to think about her options. The following day, a midwife arrived at the address Kelly had provided to administer routine postnatal care. A confused man answered the door. He said Kelly Lane hadn't lived at the property for a year and a half. Virginia Fung dialled the landline Kelly had supplied, only to find that it was a wrong number. She called Kelly's mobile, but it went straight to voicemail. When Kelly arrived for a pre-arranged meeting with Virginia a few
弗吉尼亚有些担心。凯莉看起来像是雅各布的慈母。弗吉尼亚担心她做出了草率的决定，几天后可能会改变主意。她开始安排将雅各布送入短期寄养家庭，同时凯莉出院去考虑她的选择。第二天，一名助产士来到凯莉提供的地址进行常规产后护理。一位困惑的男子开了门。他说凯莉·莱恩已经一年半没住在这里了。弗吉尼亚·冯拨打了凯莉提供的座机号码，结果发现号码错了。她拨打了凯莉的手机，但直接转到了语音信箱。当凯莉几天后如约与弗吉尼亚会面，
days later and was told about the midwife's failed visit, Kelly insisted it was the right address. She was staying there with Franz and the man who answered the door just hadn't been aware of this The foster care agreement Kelly entered into was only valid for one month, during which she was expected to attend access visits with baby Jacob. Once the month was over, she'd have the option of officially signing the adoption papers. But as the weeks passed by, Virginia found it increasingly difficult to get in touch with Kelly. Her mobile was almost always switched off and she only returned Virginia's calls out of hours, typically to cancel meetings at the last minute. Kelly had various explanations for her lack of availability. She said she had to travel to Canberra to sort out some issues with her UK visa, and that her ex-partner Duncan had frozen their joint bank account and she needed to see a
并被告知助产士上门失败时，凯莉坚称地址是正确的。她和弗兰兹（Franz）住在那儿，而开门的那个男人只是不知道这一点。凯莉签署的寄养协议有效期仅为一个月，在此期间，她需要参加与雅各布的探视。一个月结束后，她将可以选择正式签署收养文件。但随着几周过去，弗吉尼亚发现越来越难联系到凯莉。她的手机几乎总是关机，而且她只在工作时间之外回电，通常是在最后一刻取消会面。凯莉对自己的失联有各种解释。她说她必须去堪培拉处理一些英国签证的问题，而且她的前任邓肯冻结了他们的联名银行账户，她需要见一位
solicitor to sort it out. Virginia was a consummate professional who treated all the mothers she worked with compassionately. But she couldn't help but feel that Kelly Lane wasn't being completely honest. Virginia wondered whether Kelly was purposely stalling the adoption process because she was reluctant about moving forward. During the few visits she'd had with Jacob, she'd been very loving towards him, bringing him presents and shedding tears over the agonising decision she faced. As the one-month deadline approached, Kelly finally agreed to meet with Virginia to sign the adoption papers. But when the day came, she failed to show. Virginia tried the number of a friend Kelly said could offer her support. That
律师来解决这个问题。弗吉尼亚是一位非常专业的社会工作者，她以同情心对待所有合作的母亲。但她不禁觉得凯莉·莱恩并没有完全诚实。弗吉尼亚怀疑凯莉是否在故意拖延收养程序，因为她对继续进行下去感到犹豫。在与雅各布见面的几次中，她对他非常有爱心，给他带礼物，并为她面临的痛苦决定流泪。随着一个月期限的临近，凯莉终于同意与弗吉尼亚会面签署收养文件。但当那一天到来时，她没有出现。弗吉尼亚尝试了凯莉说可以为她提供支持的一位朋友的号码。那个
too was false. The foster care agreement expired, leaving Virginia with no choice but to hand the case to the New South Wales Department of Community Services, or DOCS. In the eyes of the law, Kelly had technically abandoned her baby boy. Virginia had also been unsuccessfully trying to make contact with the Jacobs father, Kelly's ex, Duncan Gillies. Kelly kept saying she'd give Virginia Duncan's UK phone number, but she'd failed to do so. Not sure what else to do, Virginia wrote a letter to Duncan's UK phone number, but she'd failed to do so. Not sure what else to do, Virginia wrote a letter to Duncan's former rugby club in Sydney in the hopes they could forward it on to him. Shortly after, Duncan called Virginia in a state of shock.
号码也是假的。寄养协议到期，弗吉尼亚别无选择，只能将案件移交给新南威尔士州社区服务部（DOCS）。在法律眼中，凯莉在技术上遗弃了她的男婴。弗吉尼亚也一直试图联系雅各布的父亲、凯莉的前任邓肯·吉利斯，但没有成功。凯莉一直说她会给弗吉尼亚邓肯的英国电话号码，但她一直没给。不知道还能做什么，弗吉尼亚给邓肯在悉尼的前橄榄球俱乐部写了一封信，希望他们能转交给他。不久之后，邓肯处于震惊中给弗吉尼亚打了电话。
As far as he was concerned, there was no way he could be Jacob's father. While he and Kelly had been a couple for several years during their early 20s, Duncan said their relationship had ended about 18 months prior and they hadn't had contact since. Duncan had moved to London for a period of time, but as far as he knew, Kelly still lived in Sydney and always had. Virginia confronted Kelly with this information. Kelly broke down, admitting she made the story up because she thought it would be better if Jacob grew up thinking he'd been the result of a loving, long-term relationship. Kelly said that Jacob's father was actually a man named Aaron Williams, an Aussie she'd met while living in London. Kelly told Virginia that Aaron knew about
据他所知，他不可能成为雅各布的父亲。虽然他和凯莉在20岁出头时曾交往过几年，但邓肯说他们的关系在18个月前就结束了，此后他们没有任何联系。邓肯曾去伦敦住过一段时间，但据他所知，凯莉一直住在悉尼。弗吉尼亚用这些信息与凯莉对质。凯莉崩溃了，承认她编造了这个故事，因为她认为如果雅各布长大后认为自己是一段充满爱的长期关系的结晶，那会更好。凯莉说雅各布的父亲实际上是一个名叫亚伦·威廉姆斯（Aaron Williams）的男人，是她在伦敦生活时认识的一个澳大利亚人。凯莉告诉弗吉尼亚，亚伦知道
the pregnancy and had consented to the adoption. She signed an affidavit confirming this, but was unable to provide any contact details for Aaron. All she knew was that he had a university degree and worked at Barclays Bank in London. Virginia contacted the Australian and UK offices of Barclays Bank only to find that no one named Aaron Williams was employed there. This was unsurprising given Virginia already knew that Kelly had never lived in London. She was starting to have some serious concerns about Kelly's mental health and whether she was even fit to give legal consent to Jacob's adoption. In addition to giving evasive answers, being uncontactable and dragging out the adoption process,
怀孕的事，并同意了收养。她签署了一份宣誓书确认这一点，但无法提供亚伦的任何联系方式。她只知道他有大学学位，在伦敦的巴克莱银行工作。弗吉尼亚联系了巴克莱银行的澳大利亚和英国办事处，结果发现那里没有叫亚伦·威廉姆斯的人。考虑到弗吉尼亚已经知道凯莉从未在伦敦住过，这并不令人惊讶。她开始对凯莉的心理健康状况产生严重担忧，怀疑她是否具备给予雅各布收养法律同意的能力。除了给出回避的回答、无法联系以及拖延收养程序外，
Kelly had told another lie that Virginia simply couldn't make sense of. When Kelly presented at Ryde Hospital to give birth to Jacob, their records showed that she'd previously visited three years earlier, in September 1996. Kelly had been heavily pregnant at the time and asked to be induced. Staff declined to do so because she hadn't quite reached full term, but their records showed that she went on to have the child across town at Auburn Hospital. During Jacob's birth in 1999, Ryde hospital staff questioned Kelly about this previous birth. Kelly said she'd had a daughter whom she'd breastfed for six months and who had travelled with her from London to Sydney. But when Virginia Fung asked Kelly if she had any other children, she gave an entirely different
凯莉还说了另一个弗吉尼亚根本无法理解的谎言。当凯莉出现在莱德医院生下雅各布时，他们的记录显示她三年前，即1996年9月曾来过这里。凯莉当时已怀有身孕，并要求引产。工作人员拒绝了，因为她还没有足月，但记录显示她后来在城另一头的奥本医院（Auburn Hospital）生下了孩子。在1999年雅各布出生期间，莱德医院的工作人员询问了凯莉关于这次分娩的情况。凯莉说她有一个女儿，她母乳喂养了六个月，并且和她一起从伦敦旅行到了悉尼。但当弗吉尼亚·冯问凯莉是否有其他孩子时，她给出了一个完全不同的
answer. She said Jacob was her first and only child. The Doc's social worker assigned to Kelly's case, John Barovnik, obtained Kelly's medical records. If Jacob had a sister, it was only fair that it went on his records so he could contact her in the future if he so desired. John confirmed that Kelly had indeed given birth to a baby girl named Tegan in September of 1996. But she'd also given birth to another girl in March 1995 called Kayla, not her real name. The hospital records of Jacob, Tegan and Kayla each listed Duncan Gillies as the father. From the records, it was clear that Kayla had been legally adopted to a loving family,
回答。她说雅各布是她的第一个也是唯一的孩子。分配给凯莉案件的DOCS社会工作者约翰·巴罗夫尼克（John Barovnik）获取了凯莉的医疗记录。如果雅各布有一个姐姐，那么记录在案对他来说是公平的，这样他将来如果愿意的话可以联系她。约翰证实，凯莉确实在1996年9月生下了一个名叫蒂根（Tegan）的女婴。但她还在1995年3月生下了另一个女孩，名叫凯拉（Kayla，化名）。雅各布、蒂根和凯拉的医院记录都将邓肯·吉利斯列为父亲。从记录中可以清楚地看出，凯拉已被合法收养给了一个充满爱的家庭，
but John could find no record of what happened to Tegan. but John could find no record of what happened to Teagan. John called Kelly and asked her if she'd previously given birth. She admitted that she'd placed Kayla for adoption in 1995 but denied ever being pregnant in 1996 or visiting Ryde Hospital at that time. John knew Kelly was lying. He had her records in front of him and could see it for himself. But if Kelly didn't have Teagan and she hadn't been formally adopted, then where was she? John Barovnik told Kelly that he had no choice but to contact the police and inform them of the matter. Kelly wrote John a letter explaining that she intended to discuss the situation with Virginia Fung. She asked that John refrain from making any inquiries in the meantime, explaining,
但约翰找不到关于蒂根发生了什么的记录。约翰打电话给凯莉，问她以前是否生过孩子。她承认她在1995年将凯拉送去收养，但否认在1996年怀孕或在那时去过莱德医院。约翰知道凯莉在撒谎。他面前就有她的记录，他自己看得清清楚楚。但如果凯莉没有蒂根，而且她没有被正式收养，那么她在哪里？约翰·巴罗夫尼克告诉凯莉，他别无选择，只能联系警方并告知他们此事。凯莉给约翰写了一封信，解释说她打算与弗吉尼亚·冯讨论这种情况。她要求约翰在此期间不要进行任何调查，并解释说，
any inquiries in the meantime, explaining, Many people have been involved by name who actually have no knowledge of what has occurred and therefore are useless in your inquiries. Please do not contact them before giving me prior notice as they will be completely unaware of what you are talking about. A few days later, a fax from Kelly arrived at Virginia's office, which read, Dear Virginia, Firstly, thank you for all of your time, your patience and your understanding, even though I have not been entirely honest with you. I'm glad now that I can stop telling half truths and lies, and perhaps move on in my life. It must be very hard for you to understand what has been going on and why I have done the things I've done and I'm not
在此期间不要进行任何调查，并解释说，许多人被提及了名字，但他们实际上对发生的事情一无所知，因此在你的调查中毫无用处。请在给我事先通知之前不要联系他们，因为他们完全不知道你在说什么。几天后，凯莉发给弗吉尼亚办公室的一份传真到了，上面写着：亲爱的弗吉尼亚，首先，感谢你所有的宝贵时间、耐心和理解，尽管我并没有对你完全诚实。我很高兴现在我可以停止说半真半假的话和谎言，也许能继续我的生活。你一定很难理解发生了什么，以及我为什么要这样做，我也不
sure I can give you all the answers. Over all of these weeks my main concern was Jacob and making sure that he was safe and happy and that you would find him a loving and secure home. So where do I start? I'm not sure. My life for the last six years has been a nightmare. Many people, including my family, have disowned me and looking at the, I guess it's not hard to figure out why. There were three children. Obviously, I can't lie anymore as the paperwork is there. The middle child lives with a family in Perth, although I have not had contact with them for a long time. They befriended me just before I had her and supported us. I am not able to give you many details as I am not sure of them myself, if my story isn't unusual enough as it already is. I know you probably can't believe it, but I know somehow that you know I am now being honest with you."
确定我能给你所有的答案。在过去的几周里，我最关心的是雅各布，确保他安全快乐，并确保你能为他找到一个充满爱和安全的家。那么我从哪里开始呢？我不确定。过去六年的生活对我来说是一场噩梦。许多人，包括我的家人，已经与我断绝了关系，看着这些，我想不难理解为什么。有三个孩子。显然，我不能再撒谎了，因为文书工作就在那里。中间的孩子和珀斯的一个家庭住在一起，尽管我已经很久没有和他们联系了。在我生下她之前，他们和我成为了朋友并支持我们。我无法给你很多细节，因为我自己也不确定，如果我的故事还不够不寻常的话。我知道你可能无法相信，但我知道在某种程度上你知道我现在对你是诚实的。”
Kelly went on to explain that no one in her life knew the full story and she wanted to keep it that way. She said people close to her had dropped her from their lives when they found out she was going to place her babies up for adoption and she was doing her best to settle down and find some sort of stability. Kelly said her parents lived in London and she hoped to rebuild a relationship with them when visiting in a few weeks' time. I hurt mentally, emotionally and physically every day, Kelly wrote. I have to live with this for the rest of my life. I constantly feel sick. I'm always on edge. I guess I knew all along that it would all come out in the open, and in some ways, I'm glad it has. While Kelly asked Virginia to respect her need for discretion, she gave Virginia permission to share this information
凯莉继续解释说，她生活中的任何人都不知道完整的故事，她想保持这种状态。她说，当她身边的人发现她要把孩子送去收养时，他们就与她断绝了关系，她正在尽最大努力安定下来，寻找某种稳定。凯莉说她的父母住在伦敦，她希望几周后去探望时能与他们重建关系。“我每天在精神上、情感上和身体上都感到痛苦，”凯莉写道。“我必须在余生中带着这个生活。我一直感到恶心。我总是处于紧张状态。我想我一直都知道这一切最终会大白于天下，在某种程度上，我很高兴它发生了。”虽然凯莉要求弗吉尼亚尊重她对谨慎的需求，但她允许弗吉尼亚分享这些信息
with the docks worker John Barovnik. But Kelly's explanation did little to ease John's concerns about the situation. Still perplexed as to why she lied about Teigen's existence and baffled by the explanation that she'd been sent to live with a family in Perth, John passed the information on to the police. When Kelly Lane's file landed at Manly Police Station, the detective assigned to it recognised the name right away. The Lanes were well known and respected around Manly, a bustling seaside suburb in Sydney's Northern Beaches region, an area known colloquially as the Insula Peninsula, due to its close-knit reputation. Not only were the Lanes heavily involved in the local sporting community,
给DOCS的工作人员约翰·巴罗夫尼克。但凯莉的解释并没有减轻约翰对这种情况的担忧。约翰仍然对她为何撒谎否认蒂根的存在感到困惑，并对她被送到珀斯一个家庭生活的解释感到不解，于是将这些信息转交给了警方。当凯莉·莱恩的档案送到曼利警察局（Manly Police Station）时，负责的侦探立刻认出了这个名字。莱恩一家在曼利非常出名且受人尊敬，曼利是悉尼北部海滩地区一个繁华的海滨郊区，由于其紧密的社区声誉，该地区被戏称为“Insula半岛”。莱恩一家不仅积极参与当地的体育社区，
Kelly's father Rob had recently retired as a sergeant from Manly Police Station. Digging into the personal life of his only daughter wasn't exactly a welcome task. By all accounts, the blonde and bubbly Kelly was a popular social butterfly who many regarded as a golden girl. A successful athlete from a young age, she'd gone on to play water polo at an elite level, even representing Australia overseas. As far as police were concerned, Kelly's previous indiscretion wasn't a high priority. Unaware of the various versions of events Kelly had told about her second-born child, the detective looked over her file. Hospital records revealed that on the afternoon of
凯莉的父亲罗布（Rob）最近刚从曼利警察局退休，担任警长。挖掘他唯一女儿的私生活并不是一项受欢迎的任务。据各方说法，金发碧眼、活泼开朗的凯莉是一个受欢迎的社交名媛，许多人视她为“黄金女孩”。她从小就是一名成功的运动员，后来在精英水平上打水球，甚至代表澳大利亚参加海外比赛。就警方而言，凯莉之前的轻率行为并不是优先事项。由于不知道凯莉关于她第二个孩子所说的各种版本，侦探查看了她的档案。医院记录显示，在
Wednesday September 11 1996, 21-year-old Kelly had presented at Auburn Hospital in Western Sydney. This was around 35 kilometres from where Kelly lived with her parents in the suburb of Fairlight, and she'd never been a patient there before. Kelly, who was heavily pregnant, told staff that she'd been intending to have a home birth with a private midwife. However, her baby was overdue, so a home birth was no longer possible. Kelly asked to be induced instead. While she didn't bring any of her antenatal records with her, she gave staff the contact number for her midwife. After several unsuccessful attempts to contact Kelly's midwife, the Auburn hospital staff
1996年9月11日星期三下午，21岁的凯莉出现在悉尼西部的奥本医院。这距离凯莉与父母居住的费尔莱特（Fairlight）郊区约35公里，她以前从未在那里就诊过。已怀有身孕的凯莉告诉工作人员，她原本打算由私人助产士进行家庭分娩。然而，她的孩子过期了，所以家庭分娩不再可能。凯莉要求引产。虽然她没有带任何产前记录，但她给了工作人员她助产士的联系电话。在几次尝试联系凯莉的助产士未果后，奥本医院的工作人员
agreed to induce her the following day. At 8pm on Thursday September 12, baby Teagan Lee Lane entered the world. While Teagan was the image of health, the birth wasn't without complications. It turned out that Teagan wasn't overdue as Kelly had claimed, but actually appeared to be two weeks early. Kelly's placenta was retained during labour and had to be manually removed, which resulted in significant blood loss. She made a quick recovery and records showed she bonded well with her newborn daughter. Regardless, the staff were a little concerned. Kelly had shown up alone at the hospital and hadn't had a single visitor.
同意第二天为她引产。9月12日星期四晚上8点，女婴蒂根·李·莱恩（Teagan Lee Lane）降生。虽然蒂根看起来很健康，但分娩并非没有并发症。事实证明，蒂根并没有像凯莉声称的那样过期，实际上似乎早产了两周。凯莉在分娩过程中胎盘滞留，必须手动取出，导致大量失血。她恢复得很快，记录显示她与刚出生的女儿建立了良好的联系。尽管如此，工作人员还是有点担心。凯莉独自一人出现在医院，没有一个访客。
This was unusual for a young mother and they were worried about her lack of support. Social worker Alicia Bautra-Vasquez was assigned to pay Kelly a visit on Friday, September 13. Kelly told Alicia that she and Teigen's father, Duncan Gillies, had only recently relocated to Sydney from their hometown of Perth, and that's why she was alone. Duncan had every intention of being present for Teigen's birth, but Kelly being overdue complicated this plan as he had rugby commitments overseas. Kelly asked to be discharged the following day, but Alicia didn't think this was a good idea. While Kelly appeared to be happy with Tegan and was breastfeeding with no issues, she also got a bit teary at times. Although this was normal for any new mother, Alicia was reluctant
这对一位年轻母亲来说很不寻常，他们担心她缺乏支持。社会工作者艾丽西亚·鲍特拉-瓦斯奎兹（Alicia Bautra-Vasquez）被指派在9月13日星期五去探望凯莉。凯莉告诉艾丽西亚，她和蒂根的父亲邓肯·吉利斯刚从他们的家乡珀斯搬到悉尼，这就是她独自一人的原因。邓肯本打算出席蒂根的出生，但凯莉过期的情况使这个计划变得复杂，因为他有海外的橄榄球比赛。凯莉要求第二天出院，但艾丽西亚认为这不是个好主意。虽然凯莉看起来对蒂根很满意，并且母乳喂养没有问题，但她有时也会流泪。虽然这对任何新妈妈来说都很正常，但艾丽西亚不愿
to send Kelly home alone in an emotionally fragile state. She also required post-operative care. Alicia voiced her concerns to Kelly, but Kelly assured her there was no reason to worry. She explained that a lady was coming to stay with her until her parents arrived in a few days' time. Duncan was also due back from overseas the following week. In the meantime, her private midwife would take over her postpartum care. Satisfied with this explanation and happy with Kelly's recovery, on Saturday September 14, it was agreed by hospital staff that Kelly and Tegan could be discharged. At around midday,
让凯莉在情绪脆弱的状态下独自回家。她还需要术后护理。艾丽西亚向凯莉表达了她的担忧，但凯莉向她保证没有理由担心。她解释说，一位女士会来陪她，直到几天后她的父母到达。邓肯也定于下周从海外回来。在此期间，她的私人助产士将接管她的产后护理。对这个解释感到满意，并对凯莉的恢复感到高兴，9月14日星期六，医院工作人员同意凯莉和蒂根可以出院。中午左右，
the attending doctor gave Tegan one final examination before concluding she was fit to go home. Kelly completed the mandatory Medicare form and was given various pieces of paperwork to fill out, including a consent form to have a blood sample taken from Teagan known as a Guthrie test, as well as a registration form to submit to the Registry of Births, Deaths and Marriages. At around 2pm, the nurse on duty was doing her rounds when she entered Kelly's room, only to find that the mother and baby had already left. Strange, she thought, when Kelly hadn't submitted the requisite paperwork, nor told any of the nurses she was leaving.
主治医生对蒂根进行了最后一次检查，得出结论她可以回家了。凯莉填写了强制性的医疗保险表格，并收到了各种需要填写的文书工作，包括一份同意对蒂根进行血液样本采集的表格（称为Guthrie测试），以及一份提交给出生、死亡和婚姻登记处的登记表。下午2点左右，当班护士在查房时走进凯莉的房间，却发现母婴已经离开了。奇怪，她想，凯莉既没有提交必要的文书工作，也没有告诉任何护士她要离开。
Nonetheless, she was free to do as she pleased. The nurse arranged for a hospital midwife to visit Kelly in a couple of days' time to make sure everything was in order. But on Monday, the midwife program received a phone call. the midwife program received a phone call. It was Kelly calling to say she didn't require their services. Her private midwife had everything under control. Four years later, the detective assigned to look into Teagan Lane's whereabouts typed Teagan's name into the New South Wales Registry of Births, Deaths and Marriages. There was no one by that name registered as being born in September 1996 and no such birth certificate had ever been issued. While it would have been difficult to do so, it was possible that Teagan could have been registered under a different name or with a
尽管如此，她可以自由地做她想做的事。护士安排了一名医院助产士在几天后去探望凯莉，以确保一切正常。但周一，助产士项目接到了一个电话。是凯莉打来的，说她不需要他们的服务。她的私人助产士已经控制了一切。四年后，负责调查蒂根·莱恩下落的侦探在新南威尔士州出生、死亡和婚姻登记处输入了蒂根的名字。没有登记显示有叫这个名字的人在1996年9月出生，也没有签发过这样的出生证明。虽然很难做到，但蒂根有可能以不同的名字或
different date of birth. It was mandatory for parents to register the birth of their children, but failure to do so only resulted in a $1,000 fine and no particular authority followed up. It was therefore possible that Teigen's birth was simply never registered. was therefore possible that Teagan's birth was simply never registered. The detective read over Kelly's hospital records and noted that she had listed her private midwife as a woman named Julie Melville. Some around Manly Police Station recognised the name. Julie was Duncan Gilley's mother. The detective called Julie Melville and asked her about the
不同的出生日期登记。父母登记子女出生是强制性的，但如果不这样做只会导致1000美元的罚款，而且没有特定的机构进行后续跟进。因此，蒂根的出生可能从未登记过。侦探阅读了凯莉的医院记录，注意到她将她的私人助产士列为一名叫朱莉·梅尔维尔（Julie Melville）的女性。曼利警察局的一些人认出了这个名字。朱莉是邓肯·吉利斯的母亲。侦探打电话给朱莉·梅尔维尔，询问她关于
postnatal care she'd provided to Kelly Lane and baby Teagan. Julie was stunned. Not only had she not been a registered midwife in September 1996, she had no idea that Kelly had ever been pregnant, she had no idea that Kelly had ever been pregnant, let alone with her son's child. Duncan Gillies was still trying to get his head around the debacle involving the adoption of Kelly's son Jacob when he received a phone call from the detective asking about baby Tegan. Like his mother, Duncan was flabbergasted. He told the detective there was no way Kelly could have been pregnant in 1996. The two had been in a committed relationship for around four years between 1994 and 1998. Although they both had busy schedules with various sporting commitments during that time, Kelly spent several nights a week at Duncan's house in 1996. Duncan said if she'd been pregnant, he would have known about it. As for baby Kayla being born in 1995, he claimed to have no idea
她为凯莉·莱恩和婴儿蒂根提供的产后护理。朱莉惊呆了。她不仅在1996年9月不是注册助产士，她甚至不知道凯莉曾经怀孕，更不用说怀了她儿子的孩子。邓肯·吉利斯还在试图理清涉及凯莉儿子雅各布收养的烂摊子时，接到了侦探询问婴儿蒂根的电话。像他母亲一样，邓肯目瞪口呆。他告诉侦探，凯莉不可能在1996年怀孕。两人在1994年至1998年间曾有过一段约四年的忠诚关系。虽然他们在那段时间都有繁忙的体育比赛日程，但凯莉在1996年每周有几个晚上住在邓肯家。邓肯说如果她怀孕了，他会知道的。至于1995年出生的婴儿凯拉，他声称对此一无所知
about that pregnancy either. Although the detective was confused by these reactions, it took three months before he reached out to Kelly Lane directly. By this point, 15 months had passed since Doc's social worker John Barovnik first alerted the police to the unknown whereabouts of Teagan Lane. Kelly's life had changed significantly during that time. Jacob's adoption had been finalised and Kelly commenced a new relationship with a family friend. By the time she was brought into the police station on Wednesday February 14,
关于那次怀孕。虽然侦探对这些反应感到困惑，但他花了三个月才直接联系凯莉·莱恩。此时，距离DOCS社会工作者约翰·巴罗夫尼克首次向警方通报蒂根·莱恩下落不明已经过去了15个月。在此期间，凯莉的生活发生了重大变化。雅各布的收养已经完成，凯莉与一位家庭朋友开始了新的关系。当她在2月14日星期三被带到警察局时，
2001 for her first formal interview, she was seven months pregnant with baby number four. When asked to describe the circumstances of Teigen's birth and the subsequent events, Kelly's discomfort was obvious. She admitted that in late 1995, during her relationship with Duncan Gillies, she'd met an older man named Andrew Morris. The two had a brief affair and in March 1996, Kelly discovered she was pregnant with Andrew's baby. This wasn't welcome news. Kelly was a student at the time and she didn't feel financially or mentally
2001年进行第一次正式采访时，她已经怀上了第四个孩子，怀孕七个月。当被要求描述蒂根出生的情况及随后的事件时，凯莉的不适显而易见。她承认在1995年底，在与邓肯·吉利斯的关系期间，她认识了一位名叫安德鲁·莫里斯（Andrew Morris）的年长男子。两人有过一段短暂的恋情，1996年3月，凯莉发现自己怀上了安德鲁的孩子。这不是受欢迎的消息。凯莉当时还是个学生，她觉得在经济上或心理上都没有
prepared to raise a child. Kelly told the detective that she and Andrew came to an agreement. She would carry the baby to full term and Andrew and his girlfriend Mel would then take custody of Tegan. As Kelly explained, Kelly said that she was discharged from hospital around midday on Saturday September 14 1996, at which point Andrew, Mel and Andrew's mother came to take custody of Tegan. Kelly recalled that Andrew dropped her at Duncan's house where she was living part time and then took Tegan with him into his care. She claimed she saw Tegan a number of times after that, but the visit stopped in early 1997 when Tegan would have been about four months old. Kelly said she'd had no contact with Andrew Melo Tegan after that and she no longer knew where they were. Kelly said that at the time of their affair, Andrew had lived in Balmain, an affluent inner
准备好抚养孩子。凯莉告诉侦探，她和安德鲁达成了一项协议。她会足月生下孩子，然后安德鲁和他的女友梅尔（Mel）将获得蒂根的监护权。正如凯莉所解释的那样，凯莉说她在1996年9月14日星期六中午左右出院，当时安德鲁、梅尔和安德鲁的母亲来接管蒂根。凯莉回忆说，安德鲁把她送到她半工半读居住的邓肯家，然后带着蒂根去照顾她。她声称在那之后她见过蒂根几次，但探视在1997年初停止了，当时蒂根大约四个月大。凯莉说她在那之后与安德鲁、梅尔和蒂根没有任何联系，她不再知道他们在哪里。凯莉说，在他们恋情期间，安德鲁住在巴尔曼，一个富裕的内城
city suburb about 18 kilometres south-west of Manly. While she didn't think she'd be able to identify his apartment after four years, she agreed to look for his old mobile number to see if it was still active. Although Kelly's story sounded a bit odd, the interviewing detective still didn't think too much of it. Besides, Manly Police Station had bigger fish to fry. Two of their senior officers had recently been busted as part of a crackdown on corruption, and the whole station was in a state of turmoil. Kelly's case languished for the rest of the year as the corruption scandal went before the court. It was only after a major restructure of personnel that Kelly's case finally appeared on the desk of
郊区，位于曼利西南约18公里处。虽然她认为四年后她无法辨认出他的公寓，但她同意寻找他以前的手机号码，看看是否仍然有效。虽然凯莉的故事听起来有点奇怪，但负责采访的侦探并没有太在意。此外，曼利警察局还有更重要的事情要处理。他们的两名高级警官最近在打击腐败的行动中被捕，整个警察局处于动荡之中。随着腐败丑闻提交法庭，凯莉的案件在这一年的剩余时间里被搁置了。直到人员进行重大重组后，凯莉的案件才最终出现在
a new detective senior constable. Having no connection to Kelly's father, he wasted little time in looking into what he believed would turn out to be a relatively minor incident. All they had to do was locate Teagan and they could get the missing persons case off their desks for good. By the time Kelly Lane was called in for questioning a second time, 19 months had passed since she'd last spoken to the police, and it was now October 2002. 27-year-old Kelly now had a healthy baby girl called Emily, not her real name, who was 17 months old. Kelly was in a loving relationship with Emily's father and the two were doting devoted parents who were preparing to travel to the UK to spend Christmas with Kelly's partner's family. Although Kelly no longer competed in any sport at an elite level, she'd
一位新侦探高级警员的桌上。由于与凯莉的父亲没有任何联系，他没有浪费时间去调查他认为会是一个相对较小的事件。他们所要做的就是找到蒂根，他们就可以彻底结案了。当凯莉·莱恩第二次被传唤问话时，距离她上次与警方交谈已经过去了19个月，现在是2002年10月。27岁的凯莉现在有一个健康的女儿叫艾米丽（Emily，化名），17个月大。凯莉与艾米丽的父亲有着充满爱的关系，两人是慈爱、专注的父母，正准备前往英国与凯莉伴侣的家人共度圣诞节。虽然凯莉不再参加任何精英水平的体育比赛，但她
made good use of her athletic skills by becoming a much-loved physical education teacher at Ravenswood School for Girls, an esteemed private Christian school. There certainly wasn't anything about Kelly that raised any suspicions for the detective. But when she started talking, that all changed. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Renters, do you ever feel like you're trapped in a cycle of payments watching your money disappear? It's time to change the rent gang and start earning real rewards. That's where built rewards can help. Built is breaking ground as a neighbourhood rewards program that hooks you up with points on your rent. Every month, pay your rent and watch the built points roll in. Use points to jet off on a
通过成为雷文斯伍德女子学校（Ravenswood School for Girls）——一所受人尊敬的私立基督教学校——深受爱戴的体育老师，很好地利用了她的运动技能。凯莉身上确实没有任何引起侦探怀疑的地方。但当她开始说话时，一切都变了。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。租房者们，你们是否有时觉得被困在支付租金的循环中，看着钱消失？是时候改变租房游戏并开始赚取真正的奖励了。这就是Bilt Rewards可以提供帮助的地方。Bilt正在开创一种邻里奖励计划，让你在支付租金时获得积分。每个月，支付租金并看着Bilt积分滚滚而来。使用积分去
dream vacation. Put your points toward a flat or hotel stay with 500 plus airlines and 700,000 plus hotels and properties. You can also use your points to book fitness studio classes or redeem them toward a future rent payment. They're designed to meet your lifestyle. Pay rent hassle-free through the Built Rewards app. Your rent game just got a major upgrade. BILT points have been consistently ranked the highest value point currency by the points guy and bank rate. Earn points by paying rent right now when you go to joinbilt.com slash case file. Make sure to use our URL so they know we sent you. Joinbilt.com slash case file to start earning points with your rent payments today.
梦想度假。将你的积分用于公寓或酒店住宿，涵盖500多家航空公司和700,000多家酒店和物业。你还可以使用积分预订健身房课程或将其兑换为未来的租金支付。它们旨在满足你的生活方式。通过Bilt Rewards应用程序轻松支付租金。你的租房游戏刚刚得到了重大升级。Bilt积分一直被The Points Guy和Bankrate评为最高价值的积分货币。现在就去joinbilt.com/casefile支付租金赚取积分。请务必使用我们的网址，这样他们就知道是我们推荐的。访问joinbilt.com/casefile，立即开始通过租金支付赚取积分。
We've all faced the dreaded what's for dinner question. I know I have. It all too often leads to ordering takeout because it's easier. But it's never satisfying and really adds up. If you'd prefer a home cooked meal without the hassle of planning, Home Chef makes it simple and helps you save money. Home Chef brings fresh ingredients and easy chef-designed recipes straight to your door. Whether you want classic meal kits with pre-portioned ingredients, 30-minute recipes or quick microwave meals, Home Chef makes it simple to enjoy tasty, stress-free meals for the whole family. Home Chef offers over 30 meal choices each week and caters to many dietary needs. They even have a tasty, kid-friendly family menu that's perfect
我们都面临过“晚餐吃什么”这个令人头疼的问题。我知道我有过。这往往会导致点外卖，因为那样更容易。但它从来都不令人满意，而且确实会增加开支。如果你想要一顿家常饭菜，又不想费心规划，Home Chef让一切变得简单，并帮助你省钱。Home Chef将新鲜食材和简单的厨师设计食谱直接送到你家门口。无论你是想要带有预分量食材的经典餐包、30分钟食谱还是快速微波炉餐，Home Chef都能让你轻松为全家人享用美味、无压力的餐点。Home Chef每周提供超过30种餐点选择，并满足许多饮食需求。他们甚至有美味、适合儿童的家庭菜单，非常适合
for picky eaters, making dinnertime stress-free. Besides being convenient, Home Chef is also budget-friendly. Customers save an average of $86 a month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering my listeners 18 free meals plus free dessert for life and of course, free shipping on your first box. Go to homechef.com slash case file. That's homechef.com slash Casefile for 18 free meals and free dessert for life. You heard that right.
挑食者，让晚餐时间变得无压力。除了方便之外，Home Chef还很经济实惠。客户每月在杂货上平均节省86美元。Casefile Presents系列《贝克斯菲尔德3》（The Bakersfield 3）的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVoice）非常喜欢Home Chef的便利性和所提供食材的高质量。她说它还向她介绍了她以前不会做的新食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef为我的听众提供18顿免费餐点，外加终身免费甜点，当然还有首个餐盒免费送货。请访问homechef.com/casefile。即homechef.com/Casefile，即可获得18顿免费餐点和终身免费甜点。你没听错。
HomeChef.com slash Casefile. Must be an active subscriber to receive free dessert. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. While Kelly Lane repeated her story about giving Teagan to the child's biological father, there was a significant discrepancy. When interviewed in early 2001, she said the father's name was Andrew Morris. This time, she said his name was Andrew Norris, with an N. But that wasn't the only difference. Her previous account made it sound like a relatively amicable agreement, but she now
HomeChef.com/Casefile。必须是活跃订阅者才能获得免费甜点。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。虽然凯莉·莱恩重复了她关于将蒂根交给孩子生父的故事，但存在重大差异。在2001年初接受采访时，她说父亲的名字是安德鲁·莫里斯（Andrew Morris）。这一次，她说他的名字是安德鲁·诺里斯（Andrew Norris），带有一个N。但这并不是唯一的区别。她之前的陈述听起来像是一个相对友好的协议，但她现在
claimed Andrew had actually been furious with her for getting pregnant. He hated me, Kelly said. I felt like a slut. In contrast to her previous story in which she claimed Andrew had dropped her at Duncan's house after she was discharged from the hospital, this time Kelly said she took a taxi home alone. The detective pointed out this was a markedly different story to the one she'd given previously. Kelly explained that she'd lied during the last police interview because she was embarrassed and wanted to make the situation sound better. But she was resolute about one thing the name of Tegan's father was definitely Andrew Norris, not Morris.
声称安德鲁实际上因为她怀孕而对她感到愤怒。“他恨我，”凯莉说。“我觉得自己像个荡妇。”与她之前声称安德鲁在她出院后把她送到邓肯家不同，这次凯莉说她独自乘出租车回家。侦探指出，这与她之前给出的故事明显不同。凯莉解释说，她在上次警察采访中撒了谎，因为她感到尴尬，想让情况听起来更好。但她对一件事很坚定：蒂根父亲的名字绝对是安德鲁·诺里斯，而不是莫里斯。
The detective was starting to have some serious doubts. Not only had some of Kelly's details changed, there were certain elements that didn't quite make sense. For starters, if Andrew was so furious with Kelly for getting pregnant, why would he agree to take custody of their baby without so much as a DNA test to confirm the baby was indeed his? Even more perplexing, why would his partner Mel agree to raise Tegan knowing she was a result of her partner's infidelity? And if Tegan really did go to live with her biological father, why wasn't Kelly forthright about that from the get-go instead of telling hospital staff and social workers otherwise? If Kelly's story was true, investigators just had to locate Andrew Norris and the whole mess could
侦探开始产生严重的怀疑。不仅凯利的某些细节发生了变化，还有一些要素根本说不通。首先，如果安德鲁对凯利怀孕感到如此愤怒，为什么他会同意在没有进行DNA亲子鉴定以确认孩子确实是他亲生的情况下，就接手抚养他们的孩子？更令人困惑的是，他的伴侣梅在明知泰根是她伴侣不忠的产物的情况下，为什么会同意抚养她？如果泰根真的去和她的亲生父亲一起生活，为什么凯利从一开始就不直说，反而告诉医院工作人员和社会工作者相反的情况？如果凯利的故事是真的，调查人员只需要找到安德鲁·诺里斯，整个烂摊子就能
be cleared up. The problem was, Kelly said she no longer had a contact number for Andrew, nor could she remember exactly where he'd lived back in 1996. Kelly didn't know much about Andrew at all, save for the fact that he worked in finance and had studied at the University of Sydney. At the time Teagan was born, he was 30 years old, well built and tanned with bleached blonde hair. Kelly said she no longer hung around the same crowd that she did back then, but there was one friend who knew about the affair and could verify her story, a woman named Lisa Andriada. Unfortunately, Lisa had relocated to Brisbane and they had lost touch. Kelly told the detective that there were some
得到解决。问题是，凯利说她已经没有安德鲁的联系电话了，也记不清他1996年具体住在哪里。凯利对安德鲁几乎一无所知，只知道他在金融行业工作，曾在悉尼大学学习。泰根出生时，他30岁，身材魁梧，皮肤黝黑，留着漂白的金发。凯利说她不再和当年的那群人来往了，但有一个朋友知道这段婚外情，可以证实她的故事，那个女人叫丽莎·安德里亚达。不幸的是，丽莎已经搬到了布里斯班，她们失去了联系。凯利告诉侦探，有一些
diaries of hers in storage at Duncan Gilley's previous home in Gladesville. She promised to go collect them in the coming days. They might contain Andrew's old mobile number or the numbers of their mutual friends. Over the following weeks, the detective made multiple attempts to contact Kelly, but she seemed to be avoiding his calls. Increasingly convinced that Kelly was lying, the detective reached out to Medicare to see if any claims had ever been made for Teagan Lee Lane. Medicare is Australia's publicly funded health insurance scheme. Individuals are required to provide their details when visiting a doctor, dentist or hospital or when receiving a vaccination. Kelly's Medicare card still had Teigen's name listed on it. She had shown this
她的日记存放在邓肯·吉利斯在格莱兹维尔的前住所里。她答应在接下来的几天里去取回它们。这些日记里可能记录着安德鲁的旧手机号码或他们共同朋友的号码。在接下来的几周里，侦探多次尝试联系凯利，但她似乎在躲避他的电话。侦探越来越确信凯利在撒谎，于是联系了澳大利亚国民医疗保险（Medicare），查看是否有人曾为泰根·李·莱恩提出过索赔。国民医疗保险是澳大利亚的公共资助医疗保险计划。个人在看医生、牙医或去医院，或者接种疫苗时，都需要提供他们的详细信息。凯利的医保卡上仍然列着泰根的名字。她曾亲自向
to the police herself, explaining that she'd registered Teigen on her card just in case Teigen was ever in her care in the future. But Medicare records proved that there hadn't been a single claim for Teagan in six years. While it was implausible to believe that a six-year-old could have gone their whole life without needing publicly funded health care, it wasn't enough to prove Teagan was deceased. Police send a memo to all New South Wales primary schools asking if any had a student named Teagan was deceased. Police send a memo to all New South Wales primary schools asking if any had a student named Teagan who was born on September 12 1996. They also began conducting searches for Andrew Norris. In Kelly's first police interview, she recalled that Andrew celebrated his 30th birthday a couple of months before Tegum was born. This meant he would have been born around mid-1966. A search of the New South Wales
警方出示过这张卡，解释说她把泰根登记在自己的卡上，只是为了以防泰根将来由她照顾。但医保记录证明，六年来没有为泰根提出过任何索赔。虽然认为一个六岁的孩子一生中从未需要过公共资助的医疗服务是不可信的，但这还不足以证明泰根已经死亡。警方给新南威尔士州的所有小学发了一份备忘录，询问是否有学生名叫泰根。警方给新南威尔士州的所有小学发了一份备忘录，询问是否有学生名叫泰根，且出生于1996年9月12日。他们还开始搜寻安德鲁·诺里斯。在凯利的第一次警方访谈中，她回忆说安德鲁在泰根出生前几个月庆祝了他的30岁生日。这意味着他大约出生于1966年中期。对新南威尔士州
electoral roll didn't bring up any men by that name who lived in Balmain around 1996. Contact was made with the University of Sydney to see if anyone named Andrew Norris or Morris had attended classes there in the 1980s. There were no former students enrolled under either of those names. By early December, Kelly still seemed to be avoiding the police and hadn't provided any of the information she'd promised to look for. Fed up with her lack of cooperation, two detectives went to Duncan Gilley's former address in Gladesville to see if they could track down the information for themselves.
选民名册的搜索并没有发现任何在1996年左右住在巴尔曼的同名男子。警方联系了悉尼大学，查看是否有名叫安德鲁·诺里斯或莫里斯的人在20世纪80年代在那里上过课。这两个名字下都没有前学生注册。到了12月初，凯利似乎仍在躲避警方，也没有提供她承诺要寻找的任何信息。由于对她的不配合感到厌烦，两名侦探前往邓肯·吉利斯在格莱兹维尔的前住址，看看他们是否能自己查到这些信息。
When they knocked on the door, they were surprised to discover that three female police officers lived there. The detectives asked if anyone had come by asking to look through old boxes of paperwork. Nobody had. It became clear to the investigators that if Kelly was telling the truth about anything, it was that people in her life seemingly had no knowledge that she'd ever been pregnant during her early twenties. Discrete inquiries were made with some of Kelly's close friends to see if they could shed light on the Teagan Lane Andrew Norris situation. The Kelly they knew had spent her early twenties playing water polo
当他们敲门时，惊讶地发现那里住着三名女警官。侦探们询问是否有人来过，要求查看旧的文件箱。没有人来过。调查人员很清楚，如果凯利在任何事情上说了实话，那就是她生活中的人似乎根本不知道她在二十出头时曾经怀孕。警方对凯利的一些密友进行了谨慎的询问，看看他们能否揭示泰根·莱恩和安德鲁·诺里斯的情况。他们认识的凯利在二十出头时一直忙于打水球
and drinking at the pub with friends. As far as they were all concerned, the only child Kelly had ever given birth to was Emily in 2001. She was a terrific mother and an adored teacher who loved children. There was no way she would have done anything to harm a newborn baby. Police managed to track down some of Kelly Lane's former water polo teammates. Stacey Gaylord, who'd played alongside Kelly in 1996, said she'd never heard of Kelly being involved with someone named Andrew Norris. However, she did recall being suspicious at the time that Kelly might have been pregnant.
和朋友们在酒吧喝酒。据他们所知，凯利唯一生下的孩子是2001年出生的艾米丽。她是一位出色的母亲，也是一位深受喜爱的老师，非常喜欢孩子。她绝不可能做出任何伤害新生儿的事情。警方设法找到了凯利·莱恩的一些前水球队友。1996年曾与凯利并肩作战的斯泰西·盖洛德说，她从未听说过凯利与一个叫安德鲁·诺里斯的人有染。然而，她确实记得当时曾怀疑凯利可能怀孕了。
Stacey and another teammate, Taryn, both admitted they'd noticed Kelly becoming self-conscious of her body. They'd snuck a glimpse of her torso underwater to confirm their suspicions. But Kelly never spoke to either of them about it, nor did they ever broach the subject, assuming it was a private matter between Kelly and Duncan Gillies. They also knew that weight gain was a sensitive subject among young women, and they were mindful that their suspicions might be incorrect. The more the police learned, the stranger the whole scenario became. Kelly had given birth three times in the four years between 1995 and 1999. During each of those pregnancies, she'd been a dedicated water polo player who lived a very active social life and was intimate with her
斯泰西和另一位队友塔琳都承认，她们注意到凯利开始对自己的身体感到不自在。她们曾在水下偷看她的躯干以证实她们的怀疑。但凯利从未与她们中的任何一人谈论过这件事，她们也从未提起过这个话题，认为这是凯利和邓肯·吉利斯之间的私事。她们也知道体重增加是年轻女性之间的一个敏感话题，她们担心自己的怀疑可能是错误的。警方了解得越多，整个情况就变得越奇怪。在1995年到1999年的四年间，凯利生了三次孩子。在每次怀孕期间，她都是一名敬业的水球运动员，过着非常活跃的社交生活，并与她的
long-term boyfriend. While women's fashion at the time consisted of baggy, loose-fitting clothing, it was staggering to believe that she could have concealed three full-term pregnancies, especially while playing water polo in a swimsuit multiple times a week. Duncan claimed that in 1996 both he and Kelly were busy with their respective training schedules and therefore they didn't see much of each other. On the occasions they did have sex, it was in a spoon position and Kelly hadn't let him touch her belly, saying she was self-conscious because she'd gained weight. Kelly said the one person who could vouch for her story was her old friend, Lisa Andriada, whom she'd lost touch with after Lisa moved to Brisbane. Police managed to track
长期男友保持着亲密关系。虽然当时的女性时尚流行宽松的服装，但很难相信她能隐瞒三次足月妊娠，尤其是在每周多次穿着泳衣打水球的情况下。邓肯声称，1996年他和凯利都忙于各自的训练计划，因此他们见面不多。在他们发生性关系的场合，他们采用的是勺子式体位，凯利不让他碰她的肚子，说她因为体重增加而感到不自在。凯利说，唯一能为她的故事作证的人是她的老朋友丽莎·安德里亚达，她在丽莎搬到布里斯班后就失去了联系。警方设法追踪
down Lisa's email address and they sent her a message asking if she could verify a few details about Kelly Lane's relationship with Andrew Norris and the subsequent birth of their baby, Tegan. Lisa was completely taken aback. She had met Kelly while the two were completing tertiary studies at the Australian College of Physical Education and they became good friends. Lisa had never heard of Andrew Norris nor about his alleged affair with Kelly. As far as Lisa knew, Kelly was never pregnant in 1996. Lisa lived in the UK, not Brisbane,
到了丽莎的电子邮件地址，并给她发了一条信息，询问她是否能核实关于凯利·莱恩与安德鲁·诺里斯的关系以及随后生下孩子泰根的一些细节。丽莎完全惊呆了。她是在澳大利亚体育教育学院完成高等教育时认识凯利的，她们成了好朋友。丽莎从未听说过安德鲁·诺里斯，也不知道他与凯利所谓的婚外情。据丽莎所知，凯利在1996年从未怀孕。丽莎住在英国，而不是布里斯班，
and she'd never lost contact with Kelly. In fact, the two friends had recently caught up over Christmas during Kelly's trip to England. At no point had Kelly said anything to Lisa about a missing child or a police investigation. Failing to find any record of Teagan Lane or Andrew Norris, the police had no doubt that Kelly was lying. They just couldn't figure out why. It didn't make sense that she'd gone through the official adoption process with babies Kayla and Jacob, but not with Tegan. Was she trying to protect herself or someone else? Investigators considered the possibility that Kelly could have sold Teigen in a private surrogacy arrangement, which is illegal in Australia. They checked Kelly's bank accounts, but she hadn't
而且她从未与凯利失去联系。事实上，这两位朋友最近在凯利去英国旅行期间还一起度过了圣诞节。凯利从未向丽莎提起过任何关于失踪孩子或警方调查的事情。由于找不到泰根·莱恩或安德鲁·诺里斯的任何记录，警方毫不怀疑凯利在撒谎。他们只是想不通为什么。她通过了正式的收养程序收养了凯拉和雅各布，却没对泰根这样做，这说不通。她是在试图保护自己还是别人？调查人员考虑了凯利可能在私人代孕安排中卖掉泰根的可能性，这在澳大利亚是违法的。他们检查了凯利的银行账户，但她并没有
received any large sums of money in 1996. She'd been a student at the time, living at home with her parents, and her bank accounts were barely touched. None of Kelly's friends recalled any changes in her spending habits. Police obtained a record of all the other babies born in Auburn Hospital on September 12, 1996. Tegan was one of only two girls born that day. The other baby girl had been stillborn. This prompted the theory, what if Kelly, in a moment of desperation, had broken a deal with the bereaved mother? The mother of the stillborn child was tracked down. She now had two children, but neither was Teagan Lane, and she hadn't ever crossed paths with Kelly.
在1996年收到任何大笔款项。她当时还是一名学生，和父母住在一起，她的银行账户几乎没动过。凯利的朋友中没有人记得她的消费习惯有任何变化。警方获得了1996年9月12日在奥本医院出生的所有其他婴儿的记录。泰根是那天出生的仅有的两个女婴之一。另一个女婴是死胎。这引发了一个理论：如果凯利在绝望中打破了与那位丧子母亲的协议呢？那位死胎婴儿的母亲被找到了。她现在有两个孩子，但都不是泰根·莱恩，而且她从未与凯利有过交集。
In each version of events Kelly had given, she claimed that after Teagan's birth, she went back to Duncan's house in Gladesville. Working on the theory that Teagan could have been killed or died by accident, officers visited the property with a cadaver dog and conducted a cursory search. While it yielded no results, they were no longer prepared to give Kelly the benefit of the doubt. In May 2003, Kelly was summoned back to Manly Police Station for a formal recorded interview. Kelly was summoned back to Manly Police Station for a formal recorded interview. Confronted with the inconsistencies in her accounts, Kelly maintained the crux of her story, that Andrew Norris and his partner Mel had taken custody of baby Tegan. The detective asked if this was the case, why did Kelly tell Virginia Fung that Teagan had gone to live with a couple in Perth?
在凯利给出的每一个版本中，她都声称泰根出生后，她回到了邓肯在格莱兹维尔的家。基于泰根可能被杀或意外死亡的理论，警官带着搜尸犬访问了该房产并进行了初步搜查。虽然没有结果，但他们不再准备给凯利怀疑的利益。2003年5月，凯利被传唤回曼利警察局进行正式录音访谈。凯利被传唤回曼利警察局进行正式录音访谈。面对她陈述中的不一致之处，凯利坚持她故事的核心，即安德鲁·诺里斯和他的伴侣梅接管了婴儿泰根。侦探问，如果是这样的话，为什么凯利告诉弗吉尼亚·冯，泰根去和珀斯的一对夫妇一起生活了？
Kelly responded, I'm not sure where they are. I wasn't sure what Andrew was going to do. Confused by this explanation, the detective asked Kelly if she was suggesting that Andrew had relocated to Perth. Kelly replied, I'm not sure what his plans were. He wasn't going to tell me. Some of the conversations I had with Andrew indicated perhaps he wasn't going to stay in Sydney because of the embarrassment that I'd caused him. Unaware that investigators had already conducted their own inquiries, Kelly was caught in multiple lies. She claimed that she'd retrieved her paperwork from Duncan's old house but couldn't find any contact numbers for people who could verify Andrew's existence.
凯利回答说：“我不确定他们在哪里。我不确定安德鲁会怎么做。”侦探对这个解释感到困惑，问凯利她是否在暗示安德鲁已经搬到了珀斯。凯利回答说：“我不确定他的计划是什么。他不会告诉我的。我和安德鲁的一些谈话表明，也许他不会留在悉尼，因为我让他感到尴尬。”由于不知道调查人员已经进行了他们自己的调查，凯利陷入了多个谎言中。她声称她从邓肯的老房子里取回了她的文件，但找不到任何可以证实安德鲁存在的联系电话。
She also maintained that she no longer had contact with the one person who could, Lisa Andriada. The detective told her, Kelly, it's obvious that you're not telling us the truth. This matter is not going to go away. He urged Kelly to come clean. All they had to do was establish where Teagan was, and Kelly could move on with her life. The detective pressed on, you've been telling us lies for whatever reason. If you know where the child is or what happened to the child, it's your opportunity to tell us now. Kelly Lane sat in silence. She looked down
她还坚持说她不再与唯一能证实这一点的人——丽莎·安德里亚达——有联系。侦探告诉她：“凯利，很明显你没有对我们说实话。这件事不会就这么算了。”他敦促凯利坦白。他们所要做的就是确定泰根在哪里，凯利就可以继续她的生活了。侦探继续施压：“无论出于什么原因，你一直在对我们撒谎。如果你知道孩子在哪里或孩子发生了什么，现在是你告诉我们的机会。”凯利·莱恩沉默地坐着。她低头看着
at her hands which were resting on the table in front of her as though she was deep in thought. The seconds ticked by until almost a minute passed. The detective asked her again if there was anything she wanted to say. After 14 more seconds of silence, Kelly responded quietly, no. The detective then asked Kelly outright if she had killed Tegan. Kelly's demeanour immediately changed, her eyes widening as she firmly exclaimed, no I did not. Kelly said that no one else knew about the situation and she didn't want her family and friends being pulled into it. She warned the detectives that if they went poking around, no one would have any idea what they were talking about.
放在面前桌子上的双手，仿佛陷入了沉思。时间一秒一秒地过去，直到几乎过了一分钟。侦探再次问她是否有话要说。在又沉默了14秒后，凯利轻声回答：“没有。”侦探随后直接问凯利是否杀害了泰根。凯利的举止立刻改变了，她的眼睛睁大了，坚定地惊呼道：“不，我没有。”凯利说没有人知道这个情况，她不想让她的家人和朋友被卷入其中。她警告侦探，如果他们到处打听，没有人会知道他们在说什么。
This is between me and Andrew, she said. Nothing has happened to Tegan. He said he would contact me if there was an emergency. I haven't heard koo-ee from them. Not one word. I don't have anything else to say. Despite previously telling the police that she wouldn't be able to locate Andrew's former unit, Kelly agreed to accompany Manly Detectives to Balmain to see if something might trigger her memory. It had been many years since she'd frequented that side of town and Kelly couldn't remember any details that could help
“这是我和安德鲁之间的事，”她说。“泰根没有发生任何事。他说如果有紧急情况会联系我。我一点消息都没收到。一个字都没有。我没什么可说的了。”尽管之前告诉警方她无法找到安德鲁以前的住所，但凯利还是同意陪同曼利侦探前往巴尔曼，看看是否能触发她的记忆。距离她经常去城里的那一侧已经过去很多年了，凯利记不起任何能帮助
her identify the building. All she remembered was that Andrew's place was about a five to ten minute walk from the Town Hall hotel. Kelly said that over the six months they'd been seeing each other, she'd only gone back there about six times, always in the early morning hours after a night out. The police wove through various neighbourhoods until they made their way down Whisbeach Street, a residential tree-lined street dotted mostly with free-standing houses. As they passed by one of the only apartment buildings on the street, Kelly pointed it out. She thought that might be it. It was a non-descript, three-storey block of units with an undercover car park and two sets of windows overlooking the street. They got out of the car and went into the foyer. It was just as Kelly remembered.
她识别那栋建筑的细节。她只记得安德鲁的住处距离市政厅酒店步行大约五到十分钟。凯利说，在他们交往的六个月里，她只去过那里大约六次，总是在深夜外出后的清晨。警察穿过各个街区，直到他们沿着威斯比奇街走下去，这是一条绿树成荫的住宅街道，大多点缀着独栋房屋。当他们经过街上仅有的几栋公寓楼之一时，凯利指了出来。她认为可能是那栋。那是一栋不起眼的三层单元楼，有一个地下停车场和两组俯瞰街道的窗户。他们下了车，走进门厅。正如凯利记忆中的那样。
Kelly said that Andrew's unit had been on the first floor, facing the street. Although she couldn't remember which one or much else about it, a tenant on the ground floor let them in and Kelly confirmed the layout was exactly the same. This was a major breakthrough for detectives. There were only two first floor units overlooking the street, units 10 and 11. For the first time since their inquiries began, they had a possible solid lead to track Andrew Norris down. It turned out that the entire building was managed by a single real estate agency. Detectives contacted the agent, who went through their records to see if an Andrew Norris had lived there in 1996. They had no records of a tenant by that name.
凯利说安德鲁的单元房在二楼（注：澳洲一楼为Ground floor，二楼为First floor），面向街道。虽然她记不清是哪一间，也不记得其他太多细节，但一楼的一位租户让他们进去了，凯利确认布局完全一样。这对侦探来说是一个重大突破。只有两间俯瞰街道的二楼单元房，即10号和11号。自调查开始以来，他们第一次有了追踪安德鲁·诺里斯的可能线索。事实证明，整栋建筑由一家房地产中介管理。侦探联系了中介，中介翻阅了他们的记录，查看1996年是否有安德鲁·诺里斯住过那里。他们没有那个名字的租户记录。
At the time Kelly claimed to have visited the property, Unit 10 was occupied by a man named Sean Greaves. Although he was of similar age to Andrew Norris, Sean didn't fit the description Kelly had provided. When questioned, Sean said he'd never lived with a woman named Mel, nor did he know a woman named Kelly Lane. He'd never had housemates or sublet his apartment either. In 1996, Unit 11 had been leased by two brothers, Peter and Stephen Clark. Neither of them recalled ever seeing Kelly Lane in the building. One of the brothers did know a man named Andrew Morris, but he was of Asian appearance and had never visited their unit. Neither they, nor any of the other former tenants recalled ever having seen mail
在凯利声称访问该房产时，10号单元房住着一个叫肖恩·格里夫斯的人。虽然他与安德鲁·诺里斯年龄相仿，但肖恩并不符合凯利提供的描述。当被问及时，肖恩说他从未与一个叫梅的女人住在一起，也不认识一个叫凯利·莱恩的女人。他从未有过室友，也没有转租过他的公寓。1996年，11号单元房由两兄弟彼得和斯蒂芬·克拉克租用。他们都不记得在楼里见过凯利·莱恩。其中一个兄弟确实认识一个叫安德鲁·莫里斯的人，但他长相是亚洲人，从未去过他们的单元房。他们和其他前租户都不记得见过寄给
addressed to an Andrew Norris or Morris. Kelly had told the detectives that on a couple of occasions after visiting Andrew, she went straight to her early morning water polo training sessions at the Dawn Fraser Pool, which was only a short walk away. Further investigation revealed that these training sessions weren't even held at the Dawn Fraser Pool, but at another location, a 20 minute drive across town. With Kelly's lies piling up, the hunt for Andrew Norris intensified. Investigators ran a search for anyone with that name born between 1960 and 1976 in the registry of each state and territory in Australia. They ran checks with the Australian Taxation Office, the Electoral Commission, the Department of Immigration, the Roads and Traffic Authority and Centrelink. Utility and telecommunication providers who serviced the Balmain area were contacted,
安德鲁·诺里斯或莫里斯的信件。凯利曾告诉侦探，在几次拜访安德鲁后，她直接去了道恩·弗雷泽游泳池进行清晨的水球训练，那里离得很近。进一步调查显示，这些训练课程甚至不是在道恩·弗雷泽游泳池举行的，而是在城另一边的另一个地点，开车需要20分钟。随着凯利的谎言堆积如山，对安德鲁·诺里斯的搜捕行动加强了。调查人员在澳大利亚每个州和领地的登记处搜索了1960年至1976年间出生的任何同名人士。他们与澳大利亚税务局、选举委员会、移民部、道路与交通管理局和福利署进行了核查。警方联系了为巴尔曼地区提供服务的公用事业和电信供应商，
as was Australia Post. Police records were checked to see if Andrew Norris had been listed anywhere as a missing person. Eventually, they had a list of 41 men named Andrew Norris who were born in Australia between 1960 and 1976. Contact was made with most of them, but none had been in Balmain at the time Tegan Lane was conceived, nor did they know a Kelly or Tegan Lane. They decided not to extend the search to include the name Andrew Morris. Morris was a much more common surname and searching for anyone with that name born over the same 16 year period would have yielded thousands of possibilities around the country. Besides, Kelly remained adamant that Norris was the correct name, though this did little to sway detectives. They were more convinced than ever that Andrew Norris was a fictional character created
澳大利亚邮政也是如此。警方记录被核查，以查看安德鲁·诺里斯是否在任何地方被列为失踪人员。最终，他们列出了一份41名在1960年至1976年间出生于澳大利亚的安德鲁·诺里斯的名单。他们与其中大多数人取得了联系，但没有人在泰根·莱恩受孕时在巴尔曼，也不认识凯利或泰根·莱恩。他们决定不将搜索范围扩大到安德鲁·莫里斯这个名字。莫里斯是一个更常见的姓氏，搜索在同一16年期间出生的任何同名人士将在全国范围内产生数千种可能性。此外，凯利仍然坚持诺里斯是正确的名字，尽管这对侦探的影响不大。他们比以往任何时候都更确信安德鲁·诺里斯是一个由
by Kelly. But if Andrew wasn't real, then who was Teigen's father? Some suspected it was Duncan Gillies, just as Kelly initially claimed. Because Kelly never had a Guthrie test done for Teigen, there were no medical records to check anyone's DNA against. Police tracked down a man named Juan Ramirez who had lived with Duncan Gillies in 1996. According to Juan, Duncan had confided in him back then that Kelly was pregnant and that they had to keep it a secret from Kelly's family. Juan recalled Duncan saying that Kelly was going away to have the child which she would then place for adoption. Duncan Gillies firmly denied this. He didn't consider Juan a
凯利虚构的人物。但如果安德鲁不是真的，那么泰根的父亲是谁？有些人怀疑是邓肯·吉利斯，正如凯利最初声称的那样。因为凯利从未给泰根做过亲子鉴定，所以没有医疗记录可以用来核对任何人的DNA。警方追踪到了一个叫胡安·拉米雷斯的人，他曾在1996年与邓肯·吉利斯住在一起。据胡安说，邓肯当时曾向他吐露凯利怀孕了，他们必须对凯利的家人保密。胡安回忆说，邓肯曾说凯利要离开去生下孩子，然后会把孩子送去收养。邓肯·吉利斯坚决否认了这一点。他并不认为胡安是
close friend, let alone a confidant. As far as Duncan was concerned, it was just as possible that Juan could be Teagan's father. Police considered this possibility too, but checks with immigration revealed that Juan hadn't even been in Australia at the time of Teigen's conception. It was calculated that Teigen would have been conceived around November or December of 1995. Duncan Gillies said he wasn't even in Sydney at that time. He'd been out of town for three weeks with some friends and had bank statements to prove it. He insisted he had no idea Kelly was pregnant twice during the course of their relationship, even though they were intimate throughout. As far as Duncan knew,
亲密朋友，更不用说知己了。在邓肯看来，胡安同样有可能是泰根的父亲。警方也考虑了这种可能性，但移民局的核查显示，胡安在泰根受孕时甚至不在澳大利亚。据推算，泰根是在1995年11月或12月左右受孕的。邓肯·吉利斯说他当时甚至不在悉尼。他和朋友们出城了三周，并有银行对账单证明这一点。他坚持说他不知道凯利在他们交往期间怀孕了两次，尽管他们一直保持着亲密关系。据邓肯所知，
Kelly had been taking the contraceptive pill the whole time they were together. By the start of 2004, it had been several months since police had any contact with Kelly. They'd been busy behind the scenes, cross-checking her stories, making discreet inquiries with her friends and searching for the elusive Andrew Norris. The more they discovered, the more convinced they became that Kelly was covering up something major. On Thursday January 8 2004, Kelly was summoned back to Manly Police Station for her third formal interview regarding Teegans' whereabouts. By this time, she was busy planning her wedding, which was set to take place the following month. Kelly grew visibly upset upon learning that the police had contacted her friends, despite her insistence that none knew anything about the matter.
凯利在他们在一起的整个时间里都在服用避孕药。到2004年初，警方已经有几个月没有与凯利联系了。他们在幕后一直很忙，交叉核对她的故事，与她的朋友进行谨慎的询问，并寻找难以捉摸的安德鲁·诺里斯。他们发现的越多，就越确信凯利在掩盖一件大事。2004年1月8日星期四，凯利被传唤回曼利警察局，进行关于泰根下落的第三次正式访谈。此时，她正忙于筹备婚礼，婚礼定于下个月举行。得知警方联系了她的朋友后，凯利明显感到不安，尽管她坚持认为没人知道这件事。
Her fiancé knew nothing about it either, and she was worried about what might happen if he found out. Exasperated, Kelly said her biggest fear was that if the issue went to court, her young daughter would be taken away from her and if her parents found out, they'd never speak to her again. Kelly again insisted Duncan Gillies was not Teagan's father. She said she'd only listed him as such on the hospital paperwork so that he'd be there if something bad happened to her. She was adamant. The father was Andrew Norris.
她的未婚夫对此也一无所知，她很担心如果他发现了会发生什么。凯利气急败坏地说，她最大的恐惧是，如果这个问题闹上法庭，她年幼的女儿会被带走，如果她的父母发现了，他们就再也不会和她说话了。凯利再次坚持邓肯·吉利斯不是泰根的父亲。她说她只是在医院的文件上填了他的名字，这样如果她出了什么事，他就会在那里。她很坚定。父亲是安德鲁·诺里斯。
Kelly claimed that she'd only found out about the pregnancy at around the 12-week mark and she didn't tell Andrew about it until a couple of weeks later. Kelly explained, He was very rude and aggressive. He said that I'd trapped him and that I was a slut. She said she didn't have any contact with Andrew again until Tegan was born, at which point he, Mel and his mother came to visit them in hospital. Prior to that, they hadn't discussed anything about what would happen with Tegan. It was only then that Andrew and Mel offered to take her. Police wondered what Kelly had intended to do with Tegan if Andrew hadn't shown up and made such an offer. She'd told no one else in her life that she was pregnant and hadn't made any
凯利声称她是在怀孕12周左右才发现的，直到几周后才告诉安德鲁。凯利解释说：“他非常粗鲁和咄咄逼人。他说我陷害了他，说我是个荡妇。”她说在泰根出生前她再也没有和安德鲁联系过，泰根出生时，他和梅以及他的母亲来医院看望了她们。在此之前，他们没有讨论过泰根会发生什么。直到那时，安德鲁和梅才提出要带走她。警方想知道，如果安德鲁没有出现并提出这样的提议，凯利打算怎么处理泰根。她没有告诉生活中的任何人她怀孕了，也没有为泰根做任何
alternative arrangements for Tegan, such as adoption or foster care. She hadn't bought any supplies indicating she intended to bring a baby home either, such as a cot, car seat, clothes, or nappies. In her first police interview, Kelly said that after handing Tegan over to Andrew, he drove her to Duncan's place. In her second, she said she caught a taxi. This time, Kelly told the detectives that she drove herself home in her own car. Years earlier, she'd told police she'd celebrated Andrew's 30th birthday at the Town Hall Hotel in August 1996. She now claimed she had no contact with him during that time. contact with him during that time. Kelly was warned that if Teigen couldn't be located, a cranial inquest would be necessary, at which point the story would no doubt leak out.
替代安排，比如收养或寄养。她也没有购买任何表明她打算带孩子回家的用品，比如婴儿床、汽车座椅、衣服或尿布。在第一次警方访谈中，凯利说在把泰根交给安德鲁后，他开车送她去了邓肯家。在第二次访谈中，她说她打了一辆出租车。这一次，凯利告诉侦探，她自己开车回了家。几年前，她曾告诉警方，她在1996年8月在市政厅酒店庆祝了安德鲁的30岁生日。她现在声称在那段时间里她与他没有任何联系。凯利被警告说，如果找不到泰根，将需要进行死因研讯，届时这个故事无疑会泄露出去。
After more than two hours of questioning, the detective told Kelly, I find it hard to believe the story you've given me. If there's anything that you wish to tell me now before we stop the interview, if there's something you've been holding back from me, I urge you now to tell me." Kelly replied, Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This episode of Casefile is sponsored by BetterHelp. Think about a time when you felt like you couldn't be your authentic self, like you were hiding behind a mask. While October is the season for costumes and disguises, many of us feel like we're wearing a mask too often, whether at work, in social situations, or with family. Therapy can help you embrace all
在经过两个多小时的询问后，侦探告诉凯利：“我很难相信你告诉我的故事。如果你在结束访谈前有什么想告诉我的，如果你有什么一直瞒着我的，我强烈要求你现在告诉我。”凯利回答说：“Casefile很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。本集Casefile由BetterHelp赞助。回想一下你感觉无法展现真实自我的时候，就像躲在面具后面一样。虽然十月是服装和伪装的季节，但我们许多人感觉自己戴面具的次数太多了，无论是在工作中、社交场合还是与家人在一起时。治疗可以帮助你拥抱
parts of yourself, allowing you to take off the veil. After all, masks are meant for Halloween fun, not for hiding our emotions. The team at Casefile are firm believers in the benefits of therapy. It's not just for those who have experienced major trauma. Therapy can teach you coping skills, help you set boundaries, and give you the space to explore your thoughts and feelings without judgement. If you've been thinking about starting therapy, consider giving BetterHelp a try. It's an online platform designed to be convenient, flexible, and tailored to your schedule. You simply fill out a brief questionnaire and BetterHelp will match you with a licensed therapist.
你自己的所有部分，让你摘下面纱。毕竟，面具是为了万圣节的乐趣，而不是为了隐藏我们的情绪。Casefile团队坚信治疗的好处。它不仅仅适用于那些经历过重大创伤的人。治疗可以教你应对技巧，帮助你设定界限，并给你空间去探索你的想法和感受，而不受评判。如果你一直在考虑开始治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。这是一个在线平台，旨在方便、灵活并根据你的日程安排进行定制。你只需填写一份简短的问卷，BetterHelp就会为你匹配一位持证治疗师。
Plus, if you feel the need to switch therapists, you can do so at any time with no extra cost. Take off the mask with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash casefile today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, h-e-L-P dot com slash case file. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Kelly Lane stuck to her story about giving Teagan to Andrew Norris, hired a solicitor, and refused to speak to the police again.
此外，如果你觉得需要更换治疗师，你可以随时更换，无需额外费用。用BetterHelp摘下面具。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠casefile，首月可享九折优惠。那是BetterHelp，h-e-L-P点com斜杠casefile。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。凯利·莱恩坚持她把泰根交给安德鲁·诺里斯的故事，聘请了一名律师，并拒绝再次与警方交谈。
A tap was placed on her phone. In one call to a friend, Kelly shared her fear of having her secret pregnancies become public knowledge. It's gonna blow wide open, Kelly said. My parents are gonna be so embarrassed and ashamed. An audibly upset Kelly confided that she was terrified of losing her daughter Emily as a consequence, stating, I used to worry so much about wanting to be a sports star and achieving these wonderful things, but the only thing I'm really good at is being a mum. Kelly's parents and fiancé were finally made aware of the situation, but they stuck by Kelly, refusing to provide formal police statements. Although the covert recordings failed to capture anything incriminating,
她的电话被监听了。在给朋友打的一个电话中，凯利分享了她对秘密怀孕成为公众知识的恐惧。“这会彻底曝光，”凯利说。“我的父母会感到非常尴尬和羞愧。”一位明显不安的凯利吐露说，她非常害怕因此失去女儿艾米丽，她说：“我过去非常担心想成为一名体育明星并取得这些了不起的成就，但我真正擅长的唯一一件事就是做一个妈妈。”凯利的父母和未婚夫终于知道了这件事，但他们支持凯利，拒绝提供正式的警方陈述。尽管秘密录音未能捕捉到任何有罪的证据，
investigators felt it was time for the case to go before the coroner. The purpose of holding a coronial inquest wasn't necessarily to find out if Kelly had done something to harm Teigen. It was to determine whether Teigen was still alive. By putting Kelly and those closest to her on the stand, they hoped that something might be revealed that exposed the truth. The inquest commenced before a closed court in mid 2004. Due to the sensitive subject matter, a media suppression order was put in place, preventing journalists from reporting on the story. As the proceedings got underway, the hunt for Teagan Lane continued.
调查人员认为案件是时候提交给验尸官了。举行死因研讯的目的不一定是查明凯利是否做了伤害泰根的事。而是要确定泰根是否还活着。通过让凯利和她最亲近的人出庭作证，他们希望能够揭露真相。研讯于2004年中期在一个封闭的法庭前开始。由于主题敏感，实施了媒体禁令，防止记者报道这个故事。随着诉讼程序的进行，对泰根·莱恩的搜捕仍在继续。
Birth and death registries for every Australian state and territory were checked for anyone who could possibly be the missing child. Working on the possibility that the wrong date of birth could have been entered, investigators widened their search to any girls born between April 1996 and September 1997. They eventually came up with a list of 12,000 individuals, but investigations into each ruled them out as being Teagan Lane. Casting a wider net, memos were sent to every public and private school across the country, as well as all homeschooling bodies. Authorities were seeking any female child born on September 12, 1996, with a father named Andrew Norris, Andrew Morris, or a father whose name wasn't listed. Checks were made with the Department of Immigration to see if anyone had applied for a passport for a baby girl between September and December 1996 who could possibly be Teagan Lane.
警方核查了澳大利亚每个州和领地的出生和死亡登记处，寻找任何可能是失踪孩子的人。基于可能输入了错误出生日期的可能性，调查人员扩大了搜索范围，寻找1996年4月至1997年9月间出生的任何女孩。他们最终列出了一份12,000人的名单，但对每个人的调查都排除了她们是泰根·莱恩的可能性。为了撒下更大的网，警方给全国所有的公立和私立学校以及所有的家庭教育机构发送了备忘录。当局正在寻找任何出生于1996年9月12日的女性儿童，其父亲名叫安德鲁·诺里斯、安德鲁·莫里斯，或者父亲名字未列出。警方与移民部进行了核查，查看是否有人在1996年9月至12月间为一名女婴申请过护照，这名女婴可能是泰根·莱恩。
No such child was identified. Checks with government authorities confirmed that no babies had been anonymously abandoned in New South Wales in 1996. Neither did any morgues have any remains that could be a potential match to Teigen. By October 2004, it had been eight years since Teigen's birth and five years since the issue of her whereabouts first came to the attention of the police. Given how much time had passed, the coroner felt they no longer had any choice. While he wanted to respect Kelly's privacy, he also felt it was time to turn to the general public for information. As later revealed by the ABC, the coroner offered Kelly a deal. If she came clean and told them where Tegan was, he'd give her immunity. Otherwise, he had no choice but to make a public appeal.
没有发现这样的孩子。政府当局的核查证实，1996年新南威尔士州没有任何婴儿被匿名遗弃。太平间也没有任何遗骸可以与泰根匹配。到2004年10月，距离泰根出生已经过去了八年，距离她下落的问题第一次引起警方注意已经过去了五年。考虑到已经过去了这么长时间，验尸官觉得他们别无选择。虽然他想尊重凯利的隐私，但也觉得是时候向公众寻求信息了。正如后来美国广播公司（ABC）所披露的那样，验尸官向凯利提供了一笔交易。如果她坦白并告诉他们泰根在哪里，他会给她豁免权。否则，他别无选择，只能公开呼吁。
While it hasn't been confirmed what exactly he promised to give her immunity from, the coroner clarified that the offer didn't extend to potential murder charges. Kelly and her lawyers were given 10 minutes to discuss their options. They rejected the offer. Kelly's lawyer told the court, There is nothing further Kelly can add at this point in time. Both she and her family are very keen to find Teigen, to find her safe and well. are very keen to find Teigen, to find her safe and well. The media suppression order was subsequently lifted and the case was propelled into the headlines.
虽然他承诺给予她什么豁免权尚未得到证实，但验尸官澄清说，该提议不包括潜在的谋杀指控。凯利和她的律师有10分钟的时间来讨论他们的选择。他们拒绝了该提议。凯利的律师告诉法庭：“凯利目前无法补充任何内容。她和她的家人都非常渴望找到泰根，找到她平安无事。”媒体禁令随后被解除，案件被推上了头条。
An anonymous tip star soon came forward with a vital detail. It turned out that just hours after leaving the hospital on Saturday September 14, 1996, Kelly attended a wedding with the Duncan Gillies. The couple getting married were old friends of Duncan's family. Video footage of the ceremony captured Kelly as she took her seat in the church dressed in a creamy white suit despite giving birth less than 48 hours prior. At no point did she mention Teagan or what she'd just been through. When Duncan was questioned about this, he later recalled that he'd been out of town prior to the wedding but returned to Sydney specifically for the event. He'd met Kelly at her parents' house in Fairlight at around 3pm and they'd travelled to the wedding together. If this was true, with Kelly and Tegan leaving the hospital at around midday, it meant there was roughly a three-hour window of time
一位匿名举报人很快提供了一个重要细节。事实证明，在1996年9月14日星期六离开医院仅几个小时后，凯利就和邓肯·吉利斯一起参加了一场婚礼。结婚的那对夫妇是邓肯家人的老朋友。婚礼的视频片段捕捉到了凯利坐在教堂里的样子，她穿着一套奶油白色的西装，尽管不到48小时前才生下孩子。她从未提及泰根或她刚刚经历的事情。当邓肯被问及此事时，他后来回忆说，他在婚礼前出城了，但专门为了这次活动回到了悉尼。他在下午3点左右在费尔莱特的凯利父母家见到了凯利，他们一起去了婚礼。如果这是真的，考虑到凯利和泰根在中午左右离开医院，这意味着大约有三个小时的时间窗口
unaccounted for. Auburn Hospital was about an hour's drive from the Lanes house, maybe more depending on traffic. Investigators wondered what Kelly was doing for those other two hours between leaving the hospital and arriving at her parents' place, babyless, and ready to attend the wedding. While the investigation continued, the public hearing for the inquest commenced in June 2005. The most intimate details of Kelly Lane's private life became daily fodder for reporters, with readers enthralled by the prospect of an accomplished young woman with a close-knit family, a wide circle of friends, a long-term boyfriend, and various sporting coaches,
无法解释。奥本医院距离莱恩家大约有一个小时的车程，根据交通情况可能更久。调查人员想知道凯利在离开医院和到达她父母家之间的那两个小时里在做什么，当时她没有孩子，准备参加婚礼。在调查继续的同时，死因研讯的公开听证会于2005年6月开始。凯利·莱恩私生活的每一个最亲密的细节都成了记者每天的素材，读者们被一个有着亲密家庭、广泛朋友圈、长期男友和各种体育教练的成功年轻女性的前景所吸引，
successfully concealing three pregnancies without anyone asking a single question. The public was gripped by the possibility that this seemingly loving mother could have done something to harm her newborn baby, and equally fascinated by the salacious details of Kelly's personal life. Tongues wagged about how she could have become pregnant so many times and who the fathers might be. People wondered why Kelly had gone through with each pregnancy when the secrecy of it all would have been such a heavy burden for a young woman to carry alone. been such a heavy burden for a young woman to carry alone. Reporters gathered outside the courthouse each day of the hearing, snapping photos of those involved as they arrived to reluctantly provide their testimony. On the stand, Duncan Gilley said
在没有人提出任何问题的情况下成功隐瞒了三次怀孕。公众被这位看似慈爱的母亲可能做出伤害新生儿的事情的可能性所吸引，同样也被凯利个人生活中那些淫秽的细节所吸引。人们议论纷纷，谈论她是如何多次怀孕的，以及父亲可能是谁。人们想知道，既然这一切的秘密对一个年轻女性来说是一个如此沉重的负担，为什么凯利还要坚持每次怀孕。记者们每天聚集在法院外，拍摄那些不情愿地前来作证的相关人员。在证人席上，邓肯·吉利斯说
that to describe the whole situation as a hell of a shock would be an understatement. Throughout his relationship with Kelly, he'd never once suspected she was cheating on him. Duncan was forced to reveal details about his and Kelly's sex life, while Kelly's friends maintained they had no idea about her alleged affair with Andrew Norris. Those who socialised with Kelly in their early twenties testified that she was not the type of person to have a one-night stand or go off with someone else when she was in a committed relationship. Little did Kelly's friends know, Duncan had already consented to a DNA test to check against
将整个情况描述为“巨大的震惊”都算是轻描淡写。在他与凯利的整个关系中，他从未怀疑过她对他不忠。邓肯被迫透露了他和凯利性生活的细节，而凯利的朋友们则坚持说他们不知道她与安德鲁·诺里斯所谓的婚外情。那些在二十出头时与凯利交往的朋友作证说，她不是那种在有稳定关系时会发生一夜情或与别人私奔的人。凯利的朋友们不知道，邓肯已经同意进行DNA测试以核对
Kelly's first daughter, Kayla. Kayla had been conceived at a time when Duncan and Kelly were in a relationship, and her adoption papers listed him as the biological father. According to the paperwork completed by Kelly, Duncan fully consented to the adoption. The DNA results came back. Duncan was not Kayla's father. Some of Kelly's friends testified to having heard gossip that Kelly was pregnant back in 1996, but Manley's rumour mill could be toxic and they didn't think there was any truth to it. could be toxic and they didn't think there was any truth to it. Yes, Kelly's weight could fluctuate, but she was also a strongly built, athletic girl who always wore loose-fitting
凯利的第一个女儿凯拉。凯拉是在邓肯和凯利恋爱期间怀上的，她的领养文件将他列为亲生父亲。根据凯利填写的文书，邓肯完全同意领养。DNA结果出来了。邓肯不是凯拉的父亲。凯利的一些朋友作证说，曾听到过关于凯利在1996年怀孕的流言，但曼利的流言蜚语可能具有破坏性，他们认为这并非事实。是的，凯利的体重可能会波动，但她也是一个身材健壮、热爱运动的女孩，总是穿着宽松的衣服。
clothing. Therefore, they never asked her about it. Even now, with the police investigation in full swing, Kelly's friends said that they hadn't discussed the issue with her. Her husband also testified that he hadn't questioned Kelly about Tegan at any great length. Kelly's loved ones had two explanations for their lack of probing. One, it was clear to them that Kelly didn't want to discuss it. Two, she was an excellent mother and a loving, caring person. There was no way she would ever harm a child. As far as they were all concerned, if Kelly said she gave Teagan to her biological father, then that's exactly what happened. The social workers, adoption agents, and medical staff who had been involved with Kelly over the years also testified. One confirmed that if Teigen had simply been illegally adopted, the whole issue could be rectified by Kelly signing an adoption consent form.
因此，他们从未问过她。即使现在，随着警方调查的全面展开，凯利的朋友们说他们也没有和她讨论过这个问题。她的丈夫也作证说，他没有详细询问过凯利关于蒂根的事。凯利的亲人们对他们缺乏追问有两个解释。第一，他们很清楚凯利不想讨论这件事。第二，她是一个优秀的母亲，也是一个充满爱心和关怀的人。她绝不可能伤害孩子。在他们看来，如果凯利说她把蒂根交给了亲生父亲，那么事情就是这样发生的。多年来与凯利有过接触的社会工作者、领养代理人和医务人员也出庭作证。其中一人证实，如果蒂根只是被非法领养，只要凯利签署一份领养同意书，整个问题就可以得到纠正。
The coroner therefore made a public appeal asking anyone who may have adopted Teagan to come forward. When this failed to generate a response, the coroner issued a second appeal, asking people to come forward if they knew a childless couple in 1996 who'd suddenly had a baby. Meanwhile, staff at a Queensland primary school roughly 900 kilometres away received the memo about Teegan Lane and searched through their database. It turned out they had a female student enrolled who was born on September 12 1996. Her name was Teegan Chapman. Although her first name was spelt differently to Teagan Lane's, the similarity couldn't be ignored once staff realised her father's name. Alan Norris. The inquest was put on hold while investigators from New South Wales immediately travelled to Queensland to chase one of the only promising leads in the case to date.
因此，验尸官发出公开呼吁，要求任何可能领养了蒂根的人站出来。当这一呼吁未能得到回应时，验尸官发出了第二次呼吁，要求那些在1996年认识一对突然有了婴儿的无子女夫妇的人站出来。与此同时，大约900公里外的一所昆士兰州小学的工作人员收到了关于蒂根·莱恩的备忘录，并搜索了他们的数据库。结果发现，他们有一名出生于1996年9月12日的女生。她的名字叫蒂根·查普曼。虽然她的名字拼写与蒂根·莱恩不同，但当工作人员意识到她父亲的名字是艾伦·诺里斯时，这种相似性就无法被忽视了。调查被暂停，新南威尔士州的调查人员立即前往昆士兰州，追查该案迄今为止唯一的有希望的线索之一。
When Teagan Chapman's mother, Debbie, found out, she insisted police were making a mistake. Debbie's mother also gave a statement saying she'd been present for her granddaughter's birth and there was no way Debbie wasn't the mother. But the police weren't willing to take any chances. They obtained Teagan Chapman's medical records and ran a DNA test against Kelly Lane. It wasn't a match. Up until this point, Kelly's parents had been tight-lipped about the whole situation. Up until this point, Kelly's parents had been tight-lipped about the whole situation. Robert Lane accompanied his daughter to court each day, making it clear to the surrounding press that he intended to stand by Kelly no matter what. But hearing the witness testimony in court
当蒂根·查普曼的母亲黛比发现这件事时，她坚称警方搞错了。黛比的母亲也发表声明说，她曾亲眼目睹孙女的出生，黛比不可能是母亲。但警方不愿冒险。他们获得了蒂根·查普曼的医疗记录，并与凯利·莱恩进行了DNA比对。结果不匹配。直到此时，凯利的父母对整个情况一直守口如瓶。罗伯特·莱恩每天陪同女儿出庭，向周围的媒体明确表示，无论发生什么，他都打算支持凯利。但听到法庭上的证人证词，
was the first time he'd heard the full story about Kelly's three secret pregnancies. heard the full story about Kelly's three secret pregnancies. On the stand, Robert explained that Kelly's weight had always fluctuated depending on what sport she was playing at the time. In hindsight, I feel a bit foolish that I didn't notice anything, he said, but I had no reason to believe she was pregnant at all. The Lanes weren't particularly religious, and both of Kelly's parents were aware that she was sexually active. The only reason Robert could think of for Kelly concealing the pregnancies was that she didn't want to disappoint her family.
这是他第一次听到关于凯利三次秘密怀孕的完整故事。在证人席上，罗伯特解释说，凯利的体重总是随着她当时参加的运动而波动。他说：“事后看来，我对自己没有注意到任何事情感到有点愚蠢，但我没有任何理由相信她怀孕了。”莱恩一家并不是特别虔诚，凯利的父母都知道她有性生活。罗伯特能想到的凯利隐瞒怀孕的唯一原因是她不想让家人失望。
"...She was held in very, very high esteem in the family," Robert said. She was very, very well known in the community. I believe she was trying to hide this episode in her life from everyone because of those pressures. Like Kelly's friends and husband, Robert said that after finding out about the investigation he didn't feel the need to ask Kelly any questions about Teagan's whereabouts. While he agreed that Kelly's story about Andrew Norris was unusual, he accepted it unequivocally. If anything, he thought the man Kelly had an affair with had likely used a fake name. The only time Kelly's mother, Sandra Lane, attended court was when it was her turn to provide testimony. Sandra described her relationship with Kelly as very good. She didn't think she'd
“……她在家里受到非常、非常高的尊重，”罗伯特说。“她在社区里非常、非常出名。我相信她是因为这些压力而试图向所有人隐瞒她生活中的这段插曲。”像凯利的朋友和丈夫一样，罗伯特说，在得知调查后，他觉得没有必要问凯利关于蒂根下落的任何问题。虽然他承认凯利关于安德鲁·诺里斯的故事很不寻常，但他毫无疑问地接受了。如果说有什么不同的话，他认为凯利有外遇的那个男人可能用了假名。凯利的母亲桑德拉·莱恩唯一一次出庭是在她作证的时候。桑德拉形容她与凯利的关系非常好。她认为她并没有
been strict with Kelly while she was growing up and believed that they had an open and honest relationship. Sandra firmly denied having any knowledge of Kelly's three secret pregnancies. She said if she had known, she would have supported her. Sandra couldn't think of any reason why Kelly hadn't told her about them. Like the others, she admitted she hadn't asked Kelly much about it since the truth came to light. Sandra described the whole situation as incredibly distressing and said it didn't feel appropriate to have an in-depth conversation with Kelly about it. Sandra had a clear memory of Saturday, September 14, 1996, the day Kelly was discharged from hospital after giving birth to Teigen.
在凯利成长过程中对她要求严格，并相信他们之间有着坦诚的关系。桑德拉坚决否认知道凯利的三次秘密怀孕。她说如果她知道，她会支持她的。桑德拉想不出凯利为什么不告诉她。像其他人一样，她承认自从真相大白以来，她并没有问过凯利太多关于这件事的情况。桑德拉形容整个情况令人难以置信地痛苦，并说与凯利深入交谈是不合适的。桑德拉对1996年9月14日星期六，即凯利生下蒂根后出院的那一天，有着清晰的记忆。
She recalled that at around 3pm Kelly had arrived home alone to get ready for the wedding. Duncan was already dressed and waiting for her. Kelly showered and dressed, then Sandra dropped them at the wedding. At no point did she recall anything unusual about Kelly's behaviour. Anticipation was high on Monday June 27, 2005 as Kelly was expected to take the stand. But just before she was about to do so, the coroner made an announcement. He ordered that the inquest be put on hold while further investigations be conducted into Teigen's possible whereabouts. Requests were made for any CCTV footage from Auburn Hospital during Kelly and Teigen's
她回忆说，下午3点左右，凯利独自回到家准备参加婚礼。邓肯已经穿戴整齐在等她了。凯利洗了澡并换好衣服，然后桑德拉开车送他们去参加婚礼。她不记得凯利的行为有任何异常。2005年6月27日星期一，人们对凯利出庭充满期待。但就在她即将出庭之前，验尸官宣布了一个消息。他下令暂停调查，以便对蒂根可能的下落进行进一步调查。有人要求追踪凯利和蒂根在奥本医院期间的任何闭路电视录像，
stay there to be tracked down. Knowing that Kelly had likely driven herself home after being discharged from hospital, he also wanted more time for the car to be forensically examined. By the time the inquest resumed in February 2006, it had been officially running for 15 months. Nothing further had been uncovered, and the search for CCTV footage yielded no results. The now 32-year-old Kelly finally took the stand. The council assisting the coroner presented her with their first question. Can you tell this court what happened to Teagan Lane around 2pm on September 14 1996 when you left the hospital with her? At the advice of her lawyer, Kelly responded firmly, I do not wish to answer that question. With that, she was free to go. In summing up the case, the council assisting said
并留在那里。由于知道凯利在出院后很可能是自己开车回家的，他还希望有更多时间对汽车进行法医检查。当调查于2006年2月恢复时，它已经正式进行了15个月。没有发现进一步的情况，对闭路电视录像的搜索也没有结果。现年32岁的凯利终于走上了证人席。协助验尸官的律师向她提出了第一个问题。你能告诉法庭，1996年9月14日下午2点左右，当你带着蒂根·莱恩离开医院时，她发生了什么事吗？在律师的建议下，凯利坚定地回答：“我不希望回答那个问题。”就这样，她可以离开了。在总结案件时，协助律师说，
there could only be three possible options. Tegan was either with her natural father she had been given to a person unknown, or she'd met with foul play. This case can be described using a number of adjectives, she said. Bizarre, fascinating, unusual, unbelievable. However, at the end of the day, what happened to Tegan Lane is a question that still has no definite answer. Kelly's lawyer acknowledged the many lies his client had told, but explained this was because she was embarrassed about her sexual conduct and her failure to prevent unwanted pregnancies. He claimed her lies only proved she was trying to keep the pregnancy secret from everyone in her life.
只有三种可能的选择。蒂根要么和她的亲生父亲在一起，要么被送给了一个不知名的人，要么遭遇了不测。她说，这个案件可以用许多形容词来描述。离奇、迷人、不寻常、不可思议。然而，归根结底，蒂根·莱恩发生了什么仍然是一个没有明确答案的问题。凯利的律师承认了他的当事人所说的许多谎言，但解释说这是因为她对自己的性行为以及未能防止意外怀孕感到尴尬。他声称她的谎言只是证明她试图向生活中的每个人隐瞒怀孕的事实。
Kelly's lawyer stated, There is no evidence capable of establishing beyond reasonable doubt that Tegan is dead, and therefore no evidence capable of establishing any form of homicide. The coroner handed down his findings on Wednesday February 15 2006. He agreed that there were several factors supporting the possibility that Teagan Lane was still alive. Firstly, there was no forensic evidence to suggest otherwise. Secondly, the fact that Kelly placed her first and third children for adoption supported the possibility that she'd also done so with Tegan. Thirdly, it was possible that Tegan's birth was registered under a fake name and she was living under an assumed identity. However, the coroner did not accept Kelly's story about giving Tegan to a man named Andrew Norris, and he said that without Kelly testifying, he was completely unable to accept her final version of events.
凯利的律师表示：“没有证据能够排除合理怀疑地确定蒂根已经死亡，因此也没有证据能够确定任何形式的杀人罪。”验尸官于2006年2月15日星期三作出了裁决。他同意有几个因素支持蒂根·莱恩仍然活着的可能性。首先，没有法医证据表明情况并非如此。其次，凯利将她的第一个和第三个孩子送人领养的事实支持了她对蒂根也这样做的可能性。第三，蒂根的出生可能以假名登记，她可能以假身份生活。然而，验尸官不接受凯利关于将蒂根交给一个名叫安德鲁·诺里斯的男人的说法，他说，由于凯利没有作证，他完全无法接受她最终的事件版本。
The coroner stated, I find it inherently unlikely that a man with whom she was having an affair already had a partner, who initially at least was incredibly angry on learning she was pregnant, nevertheless was happy to take the child. He therefore concluded, I am comfortably satisfied that Teagan Lane is in fact deceased. While he couldn't say how or where she had died, he was confident it had happened in the days immediately following her birth and stated, I am disturbed at the possibility that Teagan may have met with foul play.
验尸官指出：“我发现，一个与她有外遇的男人已经有了伴侣，而这个伴侣在得知她怀孕时至少最初是非常愤怒的，但仍然乐意收养这个孩子，这在本质上是不太可能的。”因此，他得出结论：“我完全确信蒂根·莱恩实际上已经死亡。”虽然他无法说出她是如何或在哪里死亡的，但他确信这发生在她出生后的几天内，并表示：“我对蒂根可能遭遇不测的可能性感到不安。”
His final recommendation was that the case be handed to the New South Wales Homicide Squad for a full review and further investigation. Kelly Lane sobbed uncontrollably in her father's arms as the courtroom erupted in a state of frenzy. While the inquest's purpose had been to find answers, it only raised more questions. For those in attendance, it was clear that the matter was far from over. If anything, it was just the beginning. To be continued. When 18-year-old Nea May went missing in 2002, her family did everything they could to help the police find her.
他的最终建议是将此案移交给新南威尔士州凶杀组进行全面审查和进一步调查。当法庭陷入疯狂状态时，凯利·莱恩在父亲怀里无法控制地啜泣。虽然调查的目的是为了找到答案，但它只提出了更多的问题。对于在场的人来说，很明显这件事远未结束。如果说有什么不同的话，那仅仅是个开始。未完待续。当18岁的尼娅·梅在2002年失踪时，她的家人尽其所能帮助警方找到她。
But, like so many missing persons cases, there comes a time when the leads dry up and there's nowhere left to look. At no point have we just got on with our lives. I heard something recently that really resonated. It was a woman from America who said that you never get over grief, you learn to move forward with it. And I was like, that's the best anyone's ever described it. Niamh's sister, Fionnuala, realised that a podcast might help find the answers the family was looking for. So for the past four years,
但是，像许多失踪人口案件一样，总会有一个线索枯竭、无处可寻的时候。我们从未停止过生活。我最近听到了一些真正引起共鸣的话。是一位来自美国的女性说的，你永远无法克服悲伤，你学会了带着它继续前进。我想，这是任何人所能描述的最好的方式。尼娅的妹妹菲奥努拉意识到，播客可能有助于找到家人正在寻找的答案。所以，在过去的四年里，
I've been working with Niamh's family to take a closer look at the case. And what we found took us to places we never anticipated. Here's everything we've done. We've obviously got serious concerns about her welfare. I've just spoken to the last person to see her alive that we knew about and he's given me a bullshit story. When I first started looking into this case in 2020, it was originally intended to be a single case file episode. But the more I looked, the more I found. So Steve, he is adamant that she never made it to Go Cup Road. Stan is adamant that there's a credible sighting there.
我一直与尼娅的家人合作，更深入地研究这个案件。我们发现的东西把我们带到了我们从未预料到的地方。这是我们所做的一切。我们显然对她的安危有严重的担忧。我刚刚和我们所知的最后一个见到她活着的人谈过，他给了我一个胡说八道的故事。当我2020年第一次开始调查这个案件时，它最初打算作为一个单一的案件档案剧集。但我看得越多，发现的就越多。所以史蒂夫，他坚称她从未到达过Go Cup路。斯坦坚称那里有一个可信的目击记录。
Nehems set out for a gap year after finishing high school to test her independence, but she never made it home. What happened in those final days? And when the Blackhurst arrived, these two men got out and as soon as I saw them and I saw that Blackhurst, I thought their baddies stay away from them. Mum called me and she said, look the police are investigating now and somebody claims that they dropped her off and she was hitchhiking. What started out as a potential Casefile episode turned into a 12-part series
尼娅在高中毕业后开始了间隔年，以测试她的独立性，但她从未回家。在最后几天发生了什么？当那辆黑色赫斯特车到达时，这两个人下来了，我一看到他们，看到那辆黑色赫斯特车，我就想，他们是坏人，离他们远点。妈妈给我打电话说，看，警察现在正在调查，有人声称他们把她放下了，她当时正在搭便车。最初可能是一个案件档案剧集，后来变成了一个12集的系列，
that took over four years to research. He didn't smile or anything. He just kind of looked empty and just like get in the car. It was just kind of like aggressively like get in the car. Join me as we uncover what happened in Missing Neham, the new 12-part podcast series from Casefile Presents. Something had obviously woken me suddenly because I was disorientated. That's when I realised that there was just a cold, rough hand holding my hand because I had my hand over the edge of the bed. And I could see the outline of somebody leaning over the bed. Evil, I guess, has to be somewhat attractive, doesn't it?
花了四年多的时间进行研究。他没有笑或什么的。他只是看起来很空洞，就像“上车”。这就像是一种侵略性的“上车”。加入我，让我们揭开失踪尼娅的真相，这是来自Casefile Presents的全新12集播客系列。显然有什么东西突然把我吵醒了，因为我迷失了方向。就在那时，我意识到有一只冰冷、粗糙的手握着我的手，因为我的手放在床边。我可以看到有人俯身在床上的轮廓。我想，邪恶必须有一定的吸引力，不是吗？
Otherwise, I wouldn't be able to sneak into every corner. So I whispered to my sister, asked her if she was awake, and she said yes. I said, there's someone in the room, and she said, I know. Missing Nehiem is available now. Be sure to download and follow Missing Nehiem wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
否则，我就无法潜入每一个角落。所以我低声问我妹妹，问她是否醒着，她说醒着。我说，房间里有人，她说，我知道。失踪尼娅现在可以收听了。请务必下载并关注失踪尼娅，无论你在哪里收听播客。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。